BLUM CHAIR OF THE ASSEMBLY
BUDGET SUB COMMITTEE NUMBER
THREE AND- I'LL BE CHAIRING
POLKA TODAY'S HEARING BECAUSE
UNFORTUNATELY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
QUIRK CHAIR OF ASTM COMMITTEE
CANNOT BE WITH US TODAY. FIRST
I'D LIKE TO ANNOUNCE THAT THE E.
S. T. M. LEGISLATIVE HEARING
THAT WAS SCHEDULED FOR ONE
THIRTY IS CANCELED. THOSE BILLS
WILL BE HEARD AT THE STM
COMMITTEES NEXT LEGISLATIVE
HEARING. AND NEXT I'D LIKE TO
WELCOME YOU ALL TO THIS JOINT
HEARING OF THE ASSEMBLY
ENVIRONMENTAL SAFETY AND TOXIC
MATERIALS COMMITTEE AND THE
ASSEMBLY BUDGET SUB COMMITTEE
NUMBER THREE. TODAY WE ARE
GATHERED TO DISCUSS THE
IMPORTANCE OF A ROBUST PESTICIDE
REGULATORY PROGRAM IN CALIFORNIA
AND TO RECEIVE AN INTRODUCTORY
OVERVIEW. OF THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF PESTICIDE
REGULATION OR DPR. PESTICIDES
ARE UNIQUE FROM OTHER TOXIC
SUBSTANCES WHILE MOST
ENVIRONMENTAL TOXINS ARE AN
UNWANTED BY PRODUCT OF ANOTHER
PROCESS SUCH AS AFFLUENT FROM A
MANUFACTURING PLANT OR EMISSIONS
FROM AN AUTOMOBILE ENGINE
ENGINE. PESTICIDES ARE CHEMICALS
DESIGNED TO HARM A TARGET PASSED
AND ARE PURPOSEFULLY PURPOSELY
INTRODUCED INTO THE ENVIRONMENT
TO MANAGE VIRUSES BACTERIA
INSECTS WEEDS RODENTS AND OTHER
PESTS. PESTICIDES UNFORTUNATELY
CAN ALSO HARM PEOPLE ANIMALS AND
THE ENVIRONMENT. WHILE
PESTICIDES CERTAINLY CAN BE
USEFUL AND ARE AT TIMES
ESSENTIAL. AS SUBSTANCES WITH
INHERENT TOXICITY THE BENEFITS
OF PESTICIDE USE MUST BE WEIGHED
AGAINST TE RISKS TO PUBLIC
HEALTH THE ENVIRONMENT AND NON
TARGET ORGANISMS. IN CALIFORNIA
WE HAVE TASKED DPR WITH
PROTECTING HUMAN HEALTH AND THE
ENVIRONMENT BY REGULATING
PESTICIDE SALES AND USE AND BY
FOSTERING REDUCED RISK PEST
MANAGEMENT. WHICH IS THEIR
MISSION. OVER THE NEXT YEAR MY
COMMITTEE AND THE ENVIRONMENTAL
SAFETY COMMITTEE PLAN TO HOLD A
SERIES OF DISCUSSIONS AND
POTENTIAL HEARINGS ON WHETHER
AND HOW DPR IS EFFECTIVELY AND
EFFICIENTLY ACHIEVING ITS
MISSION. THIS HEARING IS THE
FIRST OF THOSE DISCUSSIONS AND
IS MEANT TO PROVIDE BACKGROUND
AND A BROAD OVERVIEW OF
PESTICIDE USE AND REGULATION IN
CALIFORNIA AND A DPR. SO THIS IS
THE OVERVIEW HEARING. BUT FUTURE
CONVERSATIONS WILL INCLUDE A
MORE CRITICAL LOOK AT THE PR'S
EXECUTION OF ITS MISSION. AND AT
HOW WE CAN BEST SUPPORT THEM AND
PROTECTING THE ENVIRONMENT AND
PUBLIC HEALTH FROM THE IMPACTS
OF PESTICIDES. TELL THAT TO THAT
END TODAY WITH US ONE OF
CALIFORNIA'S LEADING RESEARCHERS
TO COME BEFORE US TO GIVE A
BRIEF PRESENTATION ON HUMAN
HEALTH AND ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACTS
OF PESTICIDES WE'VE ALSO ASK HOW
E. P. A. NDP R. TO DISCUSS THEIR
VISION. ON PESTICIDE REGULATION
IN CALIFORNIA TO DESCRIBE THEIR
PROGRAMS AND PROJECTS AND
EXPLAINED HOW THEIR ACTIONS
SAFEGUARD OUR PEOPLE AND
ENVIRONMENT AND SUPPORT A
TRANSITION TO SAFER MORE
SUSTAINABLE PEST MANAGEMENT
PRACTICES. BEFORE WE GET STARTED
I WANT TO THANK THE WITNESSES
THAT WE HAVE WITH US HERE TODAY
WHO HAVE TRAVELED TO THE CAPITOL
TO PROVIDE TESTIMONY OF THE ON
THIS IMPORTANT TOPIC AND I MUST
SAY IT'S VERY NICE TO HAVE
PEOPLE ACTUALLY HERE IN THE
HEARING ROOM. PREPARED TO
TESTIFY INSTEAD OF- HAVING AT-
OVER- OF THE- AUDIO VISUAL LINKS
THAT WE'VE HAD FOR SO MANY
MONTHS NOW SO IT'S A NICE-
TRANSITION- I UNDERSTAND THAT WE
WILL PROBABLY STILL CONSISTS TEN
YEAR TO HAVE- SOME OF BOTH KINDS
OF- OF- TESTIMONY. BUT IT IS
NICE TO SEE THE TRANSITION.
PLEASE NOTE THAT THERE IS AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC TO SHARE THEIR VIEWS AT
THE END OF THE HEARING EITHER IN
PERSON OR OVER THE PHONE LINE.
WE WILL BEGIN WITH. OF. EXPERTS. WE'RE GOING TO BEGIN WITH FOR
A SECRETARY OF THE CALIFORNIA
ENVIRONMENTAL PROTECTION AGENCY
SECRETARY JARED BLUMENFELD IT'S
GOOD TO HAVE YOU HERE TODAY. IN
A LONG TIME SINCE I'VE ACTUALLY
SEEN HERE SIR. IT'S REALLY GREAT
TO BE HERE WITH ALL OF YOU AT
CHAD MEMBERS THANK YOU- J. AND-
AND- REPORT- MICHAEL THANK- SAYS
ONCE AGAIN MY NAME IS CHAIRWOMAN
HEY AT NOW IS NOT NOW WE GOT
MICROPHONE YES YEP PERFECT.
THANKS SO MUCH FOR HAVING ME
TODAY REALLY APPRECIATE IT MY
NAME IS CHAIRWOMAN HELD I'M THE
SECRETARY OF CALIFORNIA'S
ENVIRONMENTAL PROTECTION AGENCY
AND THE DEPARTMENT OF PESTICIDE
REGULATION AFFECTIONATELY KNOWN
AS DPR. IS ONE OF THE SIX BOARDS
DEPARTMENTS AND OFFICES ON THE
COUNTY PA- AS SECRETARY AND
UNDER THE LEADERSHIP OF GOVERNOR
NEWSOM- WITH SUPER PROUD OF THE
WORK HAPPENING AT DPR. TO
FURTHER ITS MISSION TO PROTECT
HUMAN HEALTH AND THE
ENVIRONMENT. THIS IS A CRITICAL
PART OF OUR BROADER WHACK AT
COUNTY PA TO SOLVE MANY OF THE
PRESSING PUBLIC HEALTH AND
ENVIRONMENTAL CHALLENGES IN OUR
STATE. THAT ARE BEING
EXACERBATED BY CLIMATE CHANGE
ENSURING THAT WE'RE PRIORITIZING
EQUITY THROUGHOUT OUR WORK IS
FOUNDATIONAL TO THE ACTIONS
TAKEN BY COUNTY PA'S BOARDS
DEPARTMENTS AND OFFICES. SIX F.
M. THAT WE'RE HAVING TRANSLATES
NATIONALLY IS OTHER STATES AND
FEDERAL AND THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT LOOK TO CALIFORNIA'S
LEADERSHIP ON THESE ISSUES. DPR
AS ROBUST PESTICIDE REGULATORY
SYSTEM IS DESIGNED TO PROVIDE
THE SAFE APPLICATION OF
PESTICIDES. TO EFFECTIVELY
MANAGE AB AND PEST PRESSURES AND
TO SUPPORT. FOOD SUPPLY
STABILITY. ONE THIRD OF THE
COUNTRY'S VEGETABLES AND TWO
THIRDS OF THE COUNTRY'S FRUITS
AND NUTS ARE GROWN IN OUR STATE.
THE AGRICULTURAL INDUSTRY
CONTRIBUTES AN ANNUAL FIFTY
BILLION DOLLARS TOWARDS
CALIFORNIA'S ECONOMY. AND DPR
OVERSEES THE STATEWIDE
ENFORCEMENT OF PESTICIDE USE
LAWS AND REGULATIONS WHICH ARE
ENFORCED LOCALLY BY THE STATE'S
FIFTY FIVE COUNTY AGRICULTURAL
COMMISSIONERS. IN PARTNERSHIP
WITH THE PR. THE DEPARTMENT ALSO
FOSTERS THE USE OF SAFER MORE
SUSTAINABLE PEST MANAGEMENT
TOOLS AND PRACTICES. DPR AS NEW
DIRECTOR JULIE HENDERSON- SPEAK
IN MORE DETAIL ABOUT THE
DEPARTMENT OF LACK OF VISION FOR
THE UTURE IS NOT JUST A MATTER
OF EFFECTIVELY REGULATING
PESTICIDES IT IS TO ACCELERATE A
SYSTEM WIDE TRANSITION TO SAFER.
MORE SUSTAINABLE PEST MANAGEMENT
. JULIE SKILL SET IS A PERFECT
FIT FULL THE DEPARTMENT AS WE
TRANSITION TO THIS NEW FUTURE.
SHE'S NOT ONLY AN INCREDIBLY
CAPABLE MANAGER- HAS A REALLY
CLEAR VISION OF WHERE SHE WANTS
TO GO. BUT ALSO HAS AN
INCREDIBLY GOOD LISTEN- AND
WHETHER THAT PHAM GROUPS OR
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE COMMUNITY
THERE'S A LOT OF STAKEHOLDER
INTEREST IN THE TRANSITION THAT
YOU ALL I'M HEARING TODAY. WITH
A CHANGING CLIMATE WHICH IS
LIKELY TO BRING NEW AND
DIFFERENT PEST PRESSURES IT'S
IMPERATIVE THAT WE ACCELERATE
THIS TRANSITION TO ADVANCE
EQUITY IN PUBLIC HEALTH. FOR
POLLINATOR AND SOIL HEALTH FOR
CLEAN AIR AND WATER THE
RECENSION TWELVE STATES
AGRICULTURAL SECTOR. WE'VE MADE
SIGNIFICANT PROGRESS OVER THE
LAST SEVERAL YEARS IN CURTAILING
THE USE OF HIGH RISK PESTICIDES.
AT THE CLOSE OF TWENTY TWENTY WE
ENDED VIRTUALLY ALL THE USE OF
CHLORPYRIFOS. A DEVELOPMENTAL
NEUROTOXIN ASSOCIATED WITH
SERIOUS HEALTH EFFECTS IN
CHILDREN AND OTHER SENSITIVE
POPULATIONS. CALIFORNIA'S ACTION
WAS FOLLOWED BY THE UNITED
STATES ENVIRONMENTAL PROTECTION
AGENCY IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE
BANNING THE USE OF CHLORPYRIFOS
AND FOOD CROPS YOU TO RESET
SHARING THE LINK TO NEUROLOGICAL
DAMAGE IN CHILDREN. AND DPR JUST
PROPOSED COMPREHENSIVE
REGULATIONS TO LIMIT THE USE OF
FOR NEONICOTINOID PESTICIDE
PESTICIDES TO REDUCE RISK TO
POLLINATORS. THE DEPARTMENT HAS
AVOIDED RESEARCH AND OUTREACH
GRANTS TO EXPAND THE SUITE OF
AVAILABLE INTEGRATED PEST
MANAGEMENT TOOLS AND PRACTICES.
AND TO ACCESS THEM TO PROVIDE
CRADLES OF CRITICAL SUPPORT TO
THIS TRANSITION. THE LEGISLATURE
HAS BEEN A KEY PARTNER IN THAT
SHIFT THROUGH SIGNIFICANT
INVESTMENT IN RESEARCH TO
INCREASE DEVELOPMENT OF
EFFECTIVE ALTERNATIVES AND
ENSURING THAT THE RESEARCH IS
TRANSLATED INTO PRACTICE. AS A
RESULT OF LAST YEAR'S BUDGET
NEGOTIATIONS DPR OPENED FIVE
POINT FIVE MILLION DOLLARS IN
GRANT OPPORTUNITIES TO IDENTIFY
NEW INNOVATIVE AND REDUCE RISK
PAST MANAGEMENT PRACTICES IN
BOTH AGRICULTURAL AND URBAN
SETTINGS. ONE SPECIFIC WAY WITH
FOCUSING ACROSS SET OUT
FOSTERING CROSS SECTOR
COLLABORATION FOR BROADER
ADOPTION OF SAFER ALTERNATIVES
ACROSS THE STATE IS THROUGH TE
SUSTAINABLE PEST MANAGEMENT WHAT
GROUP. WHICH WE CONVENING WITH
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
FOOD AND AGRICULTURE. THE
GROUP'S CHARGES TO IDENTIFY A
ROADMAP AND AMBITIOUS MEASURABLE
GOALS FOR ACCELERATING A SYSTEM
WIDE TRANSITION TO SAFER AND
MORE SUSTAINABLE PEST MANAGEMENT
IN AGRICULTURAL AND URBAN
SETTINGS. AS I MENTIONED EARLIER
EQUITY IS A CRITICAL PRIORITY
FOR CALLIE PA AND FOR THE
DEPARTMENT. FOR DPR THAT
INCLUDES BOTH THE MOVE TO SAFER
PEST MANAGEMENT PRACTICES TO
PROTECT THE HEALTH OF OUR MOST
BURDEN COMMUNITIES AND PROVIDING
THOSE COMMUNITIES WITH ACCESS TO
INFORMATION ABOUT PESTICIDES
APPLIED AROUND THEM. WE'RE
EXCITED BY THE TEN MILLION
DOLLARS IN THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO BUDGET TO DEVELOP A
STATEWIDE PESTICIDE APPLICATION
NOTIFICATION SYSTEM WHICH IS NOW
UNDERWAY. APPROVAL FROM THE
LEGISLATURE ON THIS SHOWS YOUR
LEADERSHIP ON THIS ISSUE AND WE
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING TOGETHER
AS THAT WORK CONTINUES. DIRECTOR
HENDERSON WILL BE PROVIDING MORE
DIGITAL DETAILS IN HER REMARKS
WE'RE EXCITED TO CONTINUE
COLLABORATING WITH YOU AND YOUR
COLLEAGUES ALONG WITH
STAKEHOLDERS TO ENSURE THAT THE
P. R. HASTHE NECESSARY
RESOURCES TO FULFILL ITS MISSION
TO PROTECT PUBLIC HEALTH AND THE
ENVIRONMENT. AND PROVIDES THE
STATE'S TRANSITION TO SAFER MORE
SUSTAINABLE PEST MANAGEMENT
PRACTICES. THREE OH SUPPORT THE
DEPARTMENT LAUNCH LAST MONTH A
STUDY ON ITS LARGEST REVENUE
SOURCE THE MIDDLE ASSESSMENT.
ENSURING THAT THE DEPARTMENT HAS
A SUSTAINABLE LONG TERM FUNDING
SOURCE THAT INCENTIVIZES THIS
TRANSITION IS CRITICAL. WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH YOU ON
THIS. CHIEF DEPUTY DIRECTOR
MARCIN WILL PROVIDE MORE DETAIL
ON THE MIDDLE ASSESSMENT AND THE
DEPARTMENTS MIL STUDY IN HER
REMARKS THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
TODAY AND YOUR INTEREST. AND I'M
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
YOU MAY HAVE. BURKE YOUR. THERE
WE GO THANK YOU SECRETARY-
APPRECIATE YOUR COMMENTS TO HAVE
ANY QUESTIONS FOR SECRETARY
BLUMENFELD. SEEING NONE WELL
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY AND THANK YOU. RECEIVE
NOW TO HEAR FROM DR KIM HARLEY
OF UC BERKELEY GO BEARS. DR
HARLEY IS AN EPIDEMIOLOGIST AND
PROFESSOR OF PUBLIC HEALTH AT UC
BERKELEY AND WE'VE ASKED HER TO
SPEAK TO US TODAY ABOUT WHY DO
WE AND WHY SHOULD WE CARE ABOUT
AN EFFECTIVE AND EFFICIENT
PESTICIDE REGULATORY PROGRAM. IN
CALIFORNIA. WELCOME. THANK YOU
THIS IS NOT. GOOD AFTERNOON AS
YOU'VE HEARD I'M A PROFESSOR OF
PUBLIC HEALTH AND KIM HURLEY
PROFESSOR OF PUBLIC HEALTH AT UC
BERKELEY AND I AM A LEAD
RESEARCHER ON THE JAMARCO STUDY
WHICH IS THE LONGEST RUNNING
LONGITUDINAL COHORT STUDY OF THE
HEALTH OF CHILDREN- OF
CALIFORNIA FARMWORKERS I HAVE
SPENT THE LAST TWENTY YEARS OF
MY CAREER RESEARCHING HOW
MOTHERS AND CHILDREN IN
AGRICULTURE COMMUNITIES ARE
EXPOSED TO PESTICIDES AND HOW
THIS IMPACTS THEIR HEALTH. I'M
ALSO A MEMBER OF TWO DIFFERENT
DE PR WORKING GROUP'S I SERVED
ON THE CLIP YOUR FILES AND CLICK
HERE FASSEL TURNED HIS WORKGROUP
AND I'M NOW ON THE SUSTAINABLE
PEST MANAGEMENT WORK GROUP THAT
SECRETARY BLUMENFELD JUST
MENTIONED- WHICH IS A
COLLABORATIVE EFFORT TO DEVELOP
A ROADMAP FOR SAFER SUSTAINABLE
PESTICIDE PRACTICES IN
CALIFORNIA WHILE STILL
SUPPORTING OUR VIBRANT
AGRICULTURAL INDUSTRY. SO I'VE
BEEN ASKED TO TALK TO YOU ABOUT
WHY WE SHOULD CARE ABOUT
PESTICIDE REGULATION IN
CALIFORNIA- I'M GONNA GIVE YOU A
FEW REASONS- FIRST THE
PESTICIDES THAT WE PUT ON FIELDS
DON'T STAY THERE. THEY END UP
WASHING INTO SURFACE WATERS LIKE
RIVERS AND STREAMS WHERE THEY
CAN IMPACT QUICKLY AND OUR
DRINKING WATER. ARE THEY ALSO
DRIFT INTO THE AIR INSIDE
PEOPLE'S HOMES AND EVEN INTO OUR
BODIES. SO AIR MONITORING
SYSTEMS TELL US THAT AFTER
PESTICIDES ARE USED ON FEELS
THEY CAN LATER BE DETECTED IN-
ERR UP TO TWO TO FIVE MILES AWAY
DEPENDING ON THE COMPOUNDS AND
HOW IT WAS APPLIED- IN OUR
WE FOUND THAT 98% OF HOMES HAD
DETECTABLE PESTICIDE RESIDUES IN
THEIR HOUSE DUST. IN THE LEVELS
WERE HIGHER WHEN PEOPLE LIVE
CLOSE IN A FIELD WHERE PASS
THESE PESTS AS WE USED. WE ALSO
DETECTED PESTICIDES IN PEOPLE'S
BODIES FOR EXAMPLE WE TOOK URINE
SAMPLES FROM PREGNANT WOMEN AND
CHILDREN LIVING IN A FARMWORKER
COMMUNITY. AND FOUND THAT ALL OF
THEM. HAD DETECTABLE PESTICIDES
IN THEIR URINE. WE'VE ALSO FOUND
PESTICIDES IN THEIR BLOOD
SAMPLES AND EVEN IN BREAST MILK.
SO WE KNOW PESTICIDES ARE
GETTING INTO PEOPLE'S BODIES
WHEN THEY LIVE NEAR FIELDS OR
WHEN THEY LIVE WITH PEOPLE THAT
WORK IN THE FIELDS ARE BRINGING
PESTICIDES HOME ON THEIR
CLOTHING OR OTHER PATHWAYS. THE
SECOND REASON I THINK PERSONALLY
THE MOST CRITICAL REASON. IS THE
PESTICIDE THE PESTICIDE
REGULATION IS IMPORTANT IS THAT
WE HAVE VERY STRONG EVIDENCE THE
PESTICIDE USE IMPACTS BRAIN
DEVELOPMENT OF CHILDREN LIVING
IN AGRICULTURE COMMUNITIES. OUT
ONE OF THE CLASSES OF PESTICIDES
THAT ARE JAMARCO STUDY HAS BEEN
RESEARCHING FOR MANY YEARS. IS
THE CLASS CALLED ORGANIC
PHOSPHATES WHICH ARE POTENT
NEUROTOXINS- CLIP YOUR FAUCET
YOU JUST HEARD MENTIONED. BY THE
PESTICIDE THAT WAS BANNED BY DPR
IN TWENTY NINETEEN IS AN
ORGANOPHOSPHATE IS AN EXAMPLE OF
THE ORGAN OF FACETS- AND THE WAY
WE'RE GONNA FOSSEY'S WORK IS THE
EFFECTIVELY SHUT DOWN THE
NERVOUS SYSTEM EVENTS IN SACKS.
AND THEY CAN DO THE SAME THING
IN MAMMALS INCLUDING HUMANS. WE
KNOW WHAT HAPPENS WHEN ADULTS IS
WHEN AN ADULT IS POISONED BY
ORGANIC PHOSPHATE PESTICIDES IT
CAUSES CENTRAL NERVOUS SYSTEM
DAMAGE THAT CAN LEAD TO
PARALYSIS AND EVEN DEATH. BUT
WHEN WE STARTED OUR RESEARCH
TWENTY YEARS AGO WE HAD NO IDEA
WHAT THE EFFECTS. OF CHRONIC LOW
DOSE ON GOING EXPOSURE TO
ORGANOPHOSPHATE PESTICIDES WORDS
ON THE DEVELOPING BRAIN OF
CHILDREN WHO LIVE NEARBY. SO IN
NINETEEN NINETY NINE AND TWO
THOUSAND WE ENROLLED SIX HUNDRED
PREGNANT WOMEN LIVING IN FROM
MARKET COMMUNITIES IN THE
SALINAS VALLEY OF CALIFORNIA. WE
HAVE FOLLOWED THESE WOMEN AND
THEIR CHILDREN FOR MORE THAN
TWENTY YEARS THE KIDS ARE YOUNG
ADULTS NOW. AND WE SEE THEIR
CHILDREN EVERY TWO TO THREE
YEARS AND CONTRACT SORRY ONE TO
TWO YEARS AND CONDUCT DETAILED
HEALTH EXAMS AND NERD OF
ELEMENTAL TEST BATTERIES ON THEM
. AND WHAT WE FOUND IS THE
MOTHERS WHO HAD HIGHER LEVELS OF
AGAIN A FAUCET MUSCLE
METABOLITES IN THEIR URINE
DURING PREGNANCY. HAD CHILDREN
WITH MORE ABNORMAL REFLEXES AT
BIRTH. POOR VERBAL ABILITY IS H.
THREE N. H. FIVE. LOWER IQ AT
AGE SEVEN- AND SPECIFICALLY WHEN
WE COMPARED KIDS WHOSE MOMS HAD
THE HIGHEST LEVELS WERE GONNA
FAUCETS IN THEIR BODIES TO THOSE
WITH THE LOWEST LEVELS. WE SAW A
DIFFERENCE ABOUT SEVEN I Q.
POINTS AND TO GIVE YOU SOME
CONTEXT TO THAT. THAT'S ABOUT
WHAT WE SEE WITH LEAD POISONING
KIDS WITH LEAD POISONING WE SEE
ABOUT A SEVEN POINT DROP IN IQ
ON AVERAGE. SO THIS IS A REAL
CONCERN FOR US. OF COURSE IF IT
IS A CONTROL GROUP THE CHEF OF
THE THING AND- THE SECOND PART.
YES THE NEXT QUESTION. OUR OUR
STUDY POPULATION IS OFTEN THE
SALINAS VALLEY THEY'RE ALL
LIVING IN THE SAME COMMUNITY
THEY ARE ALL LOW INCOME MOST
ALMOST ALL OF THEM ARE MEXICAN
IMMIGRANTS THAT WE HAVE IS A
VERY HOMOGENEOUS POPULATION. BUT
THEY BUT THEY ARE WHERE THEY
DIFFER IS THEIR PESTICIDE LEVELS
IN THEIR BODIES WE ALSO CONTROL
FOR OTHER FACTORS LIKE MATERNAL
IQ AT PARENTAL EDUCATION WE
CONTROL FOR A BUNCH OF THINGS.
SO BUT- THAT'S A EXCELLENT
QUESTION- WE ALSO SEE IN THE
SAME POPULATION THAT MOTHERS
EXPOSURE TO ORGANOPHOSPHATE AND
PREGNANCY IS ASSOCIATED WITH
ADHD AUTISM LIKE BEHAVIORS AND
EVEN DECREASED BRAIN ACTIVATION
ON BRAIN IMAGING STUDIES AND
THEIR KIDS- SO AT THIS POINT-
THERE IS A VERY STRONG BODY OF
LITERATURE FROM OUR STUDY AND
ALSO FROM SEVERAL OTHER STUDIES.
SHOWING ASSOCIATIONS ORGANIC
PHOSPHATE PESTICIDES WITH DELAYS
AND BRAIN DEVELOPMENT IN
CHILDREN WHICH IS ONE OF THE
MAIN REASONS CALIFORNIA PLANT
BANNED CHLORPYRIFOS IN TWENTY
NINETEEN ABOUT EIGHTEEN MONTHS
BEFORE THE FEDERAL EPA BANDIT-
BUT I DO WANT TO POINT OUT THE
CLIP PURPOSES JUST ONE OF AN
ENTIRE CLASS OF ORGANOPHOSPHATE
PESTICIDES AND WE HAVEN'T BANNED
THE OTHERS. AND THEY CAN STILL
BE USED IN AGRICULTURE- EVEN
THOUGH THEY HAVE SOME OF THE
SAME MANY OF THE SAME HEALTH
CONCERNS- AS CLIPPERS HAS CLICK
HERE FOR US. ON THE PLUS SIDE
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT WE'VE
SEEN IS THE USE OF AGAIN A
FAUCET PESTICIDES HAS DECREASED
CONSIDERABLY- OVER THE LAST
DECADE OR SO- BUT- OVER THAT
TIME. AGAIN OF FACETS OF BEEN
REPLACED BY NEWER CLASSES OF
PESTICIDES LIKE PYRETHROIDS THAT
ARE LESS ACUTELY TOXIC TO
HUMANS. BUT IT TAKES A WHILE FOR
OUR RESEARCH TO CATCH UP SO
WE'RE NOW STARTING TO SEE
EVIDENCE THE PYRETHROIDS MAY
ALSO HARM CHILDREN'S INNER
DEVELOPMENT. IN IN OUR STUDY
POPULATION WE SAW LOWER I CUES
AND CHILDREN WHOSE MOTHERS LIVE
CLOSE TO FIELDS WERE PYRETHROID
PESTICIDES REPLIED DURING THE
PREGNANCY. AND THERE IS OTHER
RESEARCH THAT'S STARTING TO
SUPPORT HIS FAMILY THESE
FINDINGS ALSO. I'M SO EVEN AS WE
REPLACE ONE PESTICIDE CLASS WITH
ANOTHER WE HAVE REASONS TO BE
CONCERNED ABOUT THE HEALTH
IMPACTS OF THE NEW COMPOUNDS-
OVER THE LAST SEVENTY YEARS OR
SO WE'VE SEEN BROAD TRENDS AND
PESTICIDE USE THE DDT OF THE
NINETEEN FIFTIES AND SIXTIES.
WHICH WAS HIGHLY PERSISTENT IN
THE ENVIRONMENT- AND ALMOST MADE
A BALD EAGLES EXTINCT WAS
REPLACED BY ORGANIC PHOSPHATES
THE DIDN'T PERSIST IN THE
ENVIRONMENT BUT WE'RE NEUROTOXIC
TO HUMANS AND ANIMALS. AS AGAIN
OF FACETS OF FALLEN OUT OF FAVOR
WE'VE NOW SEEN THE RISE OF
PYRETHROIDS AND NOW THE
NEONICOTINOIDS ANOTHER OTHER
PESTICIDES. WHICH BRINGS ME TO
THE THIRD REASON WE SHOULD CARE
ABOUT PESTICIDE REGULATION.
WHICH IS IMPACTS ON ECOSYSTEMS.
ALTHOUGH NEONICOTINOIDS APPEAR
TO HAVE FEWER HUMAN HEALTH
IMPACTS. THEY'RE VERY PERSISTENT
IN THE ENVIRONMENT THEY BUILD UP
SYSTEMICALLY INSIDE PLANTS AND A
VERY TOXIC TO INSECTS. MOST
NOTABLY THE NITTANY OWNIK
INSECTICIDES HAVE BEEN LINKED TO
CRASHES AND HONEY BEE AND OTHER
PUBLIC POLLINATOR POPULATIONS.
THEY ALSO GET INTO OUR STREAMS
AND RIVERS. LEADING TO DECREASES
IN THE DIVERSITY AND ABUNDANCE
OF AQUATIC INVERTEBRATES WHICH
CAN THEN IMPACT FISH AND BIRD
POPULATIONS THAT RELY ON THEM
FOR FOOD. AND EVEN THOUGH WE
THOUGHT THEY WERE SAFE FOR
HUMANS WE ARE NOW STARTING TO
HAVE CONCERNS. THAT THE NEW NEXT
MAY ALSO IMPACT HUMAN HEALTH
INCLUDING INCREASED RISK OF
BIRTH DEFECTS. THE HUMAN
RESEARCH ON THE NEONICOTINOIDS
IS STILL VERY NEW. AND WE'RE
JUST STARTING TO LEARN THE FULL
IMPLICATIONS- LASTLY I JUST WANT
TO POINT OUT IN CASE YOU'RE NOT
AWARE THAT A LOT OF THE BEST
RESEARCH IN THE WORLD OF
PESTICIDES IN THEIR IMPACTS- IS
DONE HERE IN CALIFORNIA. AND ONE
OF THE MAIN REASONS FOR THIS IS
BECAUSE OF THE RICH PESTICIDE
USE REPORTING DATA THE TPR
COLLECTS. IN CALIFORNIA WERE
ABLE TO MAP ALL PESTICIDE USE
DOWN TO THE SQUARE MILE AND WHEN
IT WAS APPLIED WHICH IS A HUGE
BECAUSE WE CAN'T LEARN ABOUT THE
EFFECTS OF PESTICIDES. IF WE
DON'T HAVE DATA ABOUT WHAT IS
BEING USED IN WHERE IT'S BEING
USED- SO. ADJUSTED TO SUM UP IM
SH AS I'M SURE YOU KNOW
REGULATING PESTICIDES IS
EXTREMELY CHALLENGING BALANCE OF
PROTECTING HUMAN HEALTH AND
ECOSYSTEMS WHILE ALSO SUPPORTING
AND PROTECTING. OUR VITAL
AGRICULTURAL INDUSTRY- AND I
HOPE AS YOU TALK MORE OVER THE
NEXT FEW MONTHS ABOUT HOW
PESTICIDE REGULATIONS CONDUCTED
IN CALIFORNIA. YOU ALSO TO CAN.
CONTINUE TO THINK ABOUT WHY IT'S
IMPORTANT- INCLUDING PROTECTING
THE BRAINS AND THE HEALTH OF THE
CHILDREN THEIR LIVING NEAR
FIELDS- THE FARMWORKERS WHO ARE
PICKING UP FOOD. AND
BIODIVERSITY IN OUR STATE. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. FOR YOUR-
INTERESTING TESTIMONY WE HAVE A
QUESTION FROM ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MATHIS. THANK YOU MISTER ALI
AWAY IT. IN THE STUDY IS THEIR
DIVERSIFICATION BETWEEN THE
APPLICATION OF THE PESTICIDE.
FIRST LIKE SPRAY VERSUS
PALLETIZED IN A WITH A LOT OF
CROPS ESPECIALLY WITH CLLR FOR
FOSTER. THEY'VE COMPLETELY GONE
AWAY FROM THE SPRAY THEY JUST TO
THE PALLETIZED THE DUDE THE
SIGNAGE THEY DO THESE OTHER
THINGS TO MAKE SURE PEOPLE ARE
STAYING AWAY IN THAT IT ON THE
GROUND SO THERE'S NOT AN AIR
TRANSMISSION. QUALITY SO I JUST
DOES THAT IS THERE DISTINCT
VACATION WITH TAT BECAUSE I
THINK IT'S WORTH NOTING YEAH
BECAUSE I KNOW AGRICULTURE'S
GONE A LONG WAY. TO GET AWAY
FROM MANY THINGS SO THAT WAY IT
IS SAFER YEAH NO I WOULD HAVE
WOULD SAY THAT THAT THINGS HAVE
CHANGED SO MUCH SINCE WE'VE
SINCE WE STARTED THEIR STUDY. IN
ANSWER TO YOUR QUESTION WHAT WE
DO IS WE MEASURE THE LEVEL OF
PESTICIDES INSIDE THEIR BODIES
SO WE'RE TAKING URINE SAMPLES OR
BLOOD SAMPLES WHERE WOMEN WERE
WERE AND GEO CODING WHERE THEY
LIVE RELATIVE TO THE FIELD. BUT
BUT ONE OF THE MEASURE THE
LEVELS INSIDE THE BODY WE CAN'T
ACTUALLY TELL WAT YEAH IT
FOUNDER AND VIDEO. YOU NEED TO
MAKE SURE THAT IT'S
DISTINGUISHING. IF YOU'RE
POPULATION BASE AND SAY THEY'RE
DOING A SPRAY PROCESS. VERSES
THE PALLETIZED PROCESS WITH THE
NEWER PROCESS. NEEDS TO BE A
DISTINCTION BETWEEN THAT BECAUSE
THIS REYES DEFINITELY GONNA
CARRY WHICH IS WHY THEY SWITCHED
OVER. TO THIS OF THE RESEARCH
INDUSTRY FLAG THOSE CHANGES. IN
I MEAN IT'S IMPORTANT A WITHIN
THE BODY'S WHAT'S IN THE HOME
THAT THAT'S VITAL- ON. TO THOSE
POPULATIONS EXPRESSLY. AS WE'RE
LOOKING AT THESE THINGS BUT WE
NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE
ALSO NOTING IF THE NEARBY
PHARMACY BRAIN. VERSUS IF THIRD
MOVEMENT TO THE PALLETIZED MODEL
TO KEEP. THAT DRAFT THERE. FOR
AND WE SHOULD BE ABLE TO SEE
THAT REFER IF WE LOOK AT WHAT
HOW BEING APPLY WHICH IS THAT
REFLECT IN WHAT'S INTO THEIR
HOMES AND SCATTERED ABOUT APPS
BUT IT AND WE NEED TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE KNOW YOU KNOW WHAT WHAT
IS THE PRACTICE IN THAT
COMMUNITY BECAUSE OF THE
PRACTICE IN THE COMMUNITY AND WE
CAN SHOW THE LEVELS OF GONE DOWN
SINCE WE SWITCHED TO PALLETIZED
THAT NEEDS TO BE NOTED AND I
AGREE. VERY MUCH SO. YEAH I
AGREE. ASSEMBLY MEMBER BETTER.
QUICK QUICK. QUESTION IN YOUR
FIRST STATEMENT HE SAID THAT
THEY FOUND PESTICIDES IT DID
TOO. WE KNOW THESE PESTICIDES
GET INTO PEOPLE'S BODIES AND
THEY FOUND. IT ARE WE FOR. DO WE
HAVE A CONTROL GROUP OF PEOPLE
THAT ARE FARMWORKERS- THAT ARE.
GETTING THE US VERSUS. PEOPLE
ARE NOT FARMWORKERS ANISUR
SUBSTANTIAL DIFFERENCE IN
ENGLAND A PESTICIDE. THE EASIEST
WAY FOR US TO MAKE THAT
COMPARISON. IS THAT WE NEED
THESE BIOMARKERS OF. OF
DIFFERENT PESTICIDES ARE ALSO
MEASURED- NATIONALLY. SO THE CDC
HAS A NATIONALLY REPRESENTATIVE
POPULATION IN THE ENHANCE HAND
STUDY AND WHEN WE COMPARE WITH
THE NATIONAL. POPULATION WE HAVE
SIGNIFICANTLY HIGHER LEVELS. OF
INNOCENT ISRAELI POPULATION. FOR
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS. MATHIS WITH
THAT OBVIOUSLY OUR CULTURE IN
THE SALINAS VALLEY IS DIFFERENT
SAY THAN IN THE SAN JOAQUIN
VALLEY IN EVEN DIFFERENT BETWEEN
EAST AND WEST NORTH AND SOUTH SO
I'D BE CURIOUS TO SEE WHAT OTHER
CONTROL GROUPS SHE IN THE SAN
JOAQUIN VALLEY. VERSES THE
IMPERIAL VALLEY WHAT THAT WOULD
LOOK LIKE BECAUSE THOSE
PRACTICES ARE VERY MUCH
DIFFERENT AND I THINK.
UNDERSTANDING THE DIFFERENT
APPLICATIONS. ESPECIALLY WITH
THE DIFFERENT CROPS. OF COURSE
DIFFERENT CROPS DO THINGS QUITE
DIFFERENTLY- YOU KNOW IF YOU'RE
GONNA STRAWBERRIES VERSUS
CITRUS- VERSUS PEPPERS. YOU KNOW
SO I THINK GETTING MORE INTO
THAT AS WELL- YOU KNOW SALINAS
VALLEY'S IS VERY IMPORTANT THAT
IT'S THE SALAD BOWL- BUT
UNDERSTAND IT WHAT SAY HAPPENS
IN THE CITRUS BELT YEAH BECAUSE
FEAR PROCESS HOW IT TIES
APPLICATIONS BEING DONE. IN
UNDERSTANDING WHAT THOSE LEVELS
ARE THERE- VERSUS SOMEWHERE THAT
THAT IT HISTORICALLY SPRAYED IN
NOW IS DOING SOMETHING DIFFERENT
THAT THOSE DISTINCTIONS ARE
GOING TO BE VERY DIFFERENT- IN
GOING TO BE VERY IMPORTANT FOR
US GOING FORWARD AS WE DECIDE
WHAT THE REGULATIONS ARE. I
COMPLETELY AGREE AND I WOULD
LOVE TO SEE MORE RESEARCH ON
WHAT THE PESTICIDE MIX AND WHAT
THE EXPOSURE LEVELS ARE LIKE AND
HOW THAT DIFFERS IN DIFFERENT
REGIONS OF CALIFORNIA. I THIS IS
BEEN IT'S SUCH AN IN DEPTH
EXTENSIVE STUDY OVER TWENTY
YEARS OF MORE THAN MILLION
DOLLARS A YEAR TO CONDUCT IT AND
IF WE COULD DO MORE RESEARCH
LIKE THIS AND OTHER LOCATIONS. I
THINK MY CONCERNS FIRST MISTER
CHAIRMAN IS THAT IF WE JUST HONE
IN ON THE SALINAS VALLEY. AND WE
HAVE WHAT'S HAPPENING THERE.
OBVIOUSLY THAT THAT IS VERY AND-
BUT WE HAVE TO LOOK AT THESE
DIFFERENT AREAS ESPECIALLY
AGRICULTURE ACROSS THE STATE
BECAUSE WE DO HAVE FOUR HUNDRED
EIGHT. DIFFERENT COMMODITIES
THAT ARE BEING GROWN I MEAN
THAT'S FOUR HUNDRED EIGHTY.
DIFFERENT APPLICATION PROCESSES
DIFFERENT THINGS THAT ARE
HAPPENING- SO WE NEED TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE- TAKE THAT INTO
CONCERNED. BECAUSE WE CAN'T JUST
SAY OKAY THIS. SALINAS VALLEY IS
YOU KNOW MAYBE TWENTY OF THOSE
FOR EXAMPLE NAY AMHERST ON
TWENTY OTHERS A NUMBER. BUT WHEN
YOU REALLY BREAK IT DOWN THEY'RE
STILL FOUR HUNDRED AND EIGHT
DIFFERENT COMMODITY CROPS. THAT
WE'RE LOOKING AT. AND SO THAT
THAT'S A VAST DIFFERENCE THAT WE
HAVE TO TAKE INTO CONSIDERATION
. AND I DON'T AND I THINK WHAT
I'M HEARING CUT DR HARLEY SAY
IS- THAT WE HAVE SOME TOPLINE
DATA THAT INDICATES THAT- HI
THERE ARE IMPACTS ON- YOUNG
CHILDREN THAT WE NEED TO BE
CONCERNED ABOUT BUT WE NEED TO
DRILL DOWN FURTHER TO
UNDERSTAND- YOU KNOW HOW THAT
BREAKS DOWN OF IT FOR NOW
OPERATES IN THE DIFFERENT
REGIONS OF THE STATE. AND IF I
COULD JUST MENTION THERE ARE
OTHER STUDIES BESIDES OUR STUDY
THAT HAVE LOOKED MORE STATEWIDE
LOOKING REALLY AT WHAT'S BEEN
APPLIED AND CHILDREN LIVE NEARBY
AND WE'RE SEEING SOME VERY
SIMILAR FINDINGS WHEN WE LOOK AT
THE STATE THAT Y. DATA IT'S NOT
THE SAME. LEVEL OF DETAIL IS
WHAT WE GET IN OUR SMALL
POPULATION BUT IT'S SORT OF
REPLICATED WHEN YOU'RE ABLE TO
LOOK AT A LOT MORE STATEWIDE
POPULATION CORRECT WHICH IS.
AGAIN WHY THE I THINK KNOWING
THE APPLICATION PROCESS. IN THE
DIFFERENT RECENT REGIONS IS
IMPORTANT BECAUSE WE KNOW THEY
DO DIFFERENT THINGS AND WE NEED
TO MAKE SURE THAT THE KIDS ARE
BEING TAKEN CARE OF AND THAT
THESE FAMILIES ARE BEING TAKEN
CARE OF IT IS VERY VITAL. FOR
OUR IMMIGRANT AG FARM
COMMUNITIES THAT THESE THINGS
ARE BEING DONE BUT WE HAVE TO
KNOW YOU KNOW HOW HOW ARE THEY
DOING IT WHAT'S THE COMPARISON
AND HAVE. THE CORRELATING DATA.
THANK YOU AGAIN FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY. VERY INTERESTING AND-
I UNDERSTAND WE'RE JUST GETTING
A SUMMARY TODAY BUT- APPRECIATED
NONETHELESS. NEXT UP WE HAVE-
OUR NEWLY APPOINTED DIRECTOR OF
DPR JULIE HENDERSON. TOO MANY
PEOPLE THE WORK OF DPR SEEMS SO
VERY FAR REMOVED FROM THEIR
DAILY LIVES BUT- THE REALITY IS
THE PR'S PROGRAMS AND
REGULATIONS NOT ONLY IMPACT THE
FOOD THAT WE EAT. BUT THE AIR
THAT WE BREATHE. THE WATER WE
DRINK. THE PRODUCTS WE USE IN
OUR HOMES. AND MANY OTHER
ASPECTS OF OUR LIVES NO PRESSURE
. WE'VE ASKED DR GRANT DIRECTOR
HENDERSON TO EXPLAIN TO US WHAT
EXACTLY IT IS THAT THE P. R.
DOES WHAT THE HECK IS IT THAT
YOU DO- AND TO- HOW- DIFFERENT
PROGRAMS AND PROJECTS ALIGNED
WITH DVRS MISSION OF. HUMAN
HEALTH AND ENVIRONMENTAL
PROTECTION IN THE TRANSITION TO
SAFER PEST MANAGEMENT PRACTICES.
ON THE SINCE A- DIRECTOR
MORRISON. I EXCUSE ME SINCE- THE
FOLLOWING WITNESS- KAREN
MORRISON WILL DISCUSS DVRS
FUNDING SOURCES AND HOW THOSE
FUNDS SUPPORT THEIR PROGRAMS.
MEMBERS MAY WISH TO HOLD THEIR
QUESTIONS UNTIL AFTER WE'VE
HEARD FROM BOTH OF THESE
WITNESSES AND WITH THAT OF A LOT
WELCOME JULIE ANDERSON. THANK
YOU SO MUCH- CHERRY BLOOM AND-
GOOD AFTERNOON. MY NAME IS JULIE
HENDERSON AND I'M THE DIRECTOR
OF THE DEPARTMENT OF PESTICIDE
REGULATION I'VE BEEN IN THIS
ROLE SINCE JULY OF LAST YEAR
FIRST AS ACTING DIRECTOR AND
THEN- AS OF DECEMBER APPOINTED
DIRECTOR- BEFORE TAKING THIS
ROLE I WAS A DEPUTY SECRETARY
AND THERE ARE WORKED VERY
CLOSELY WITH THE DEPARTMENT AS
WELL AS WITH THE OFFICE OF
ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH HAZARD
ASSESSMENT ON PRIORITY POLICY
ISSUES IMPACTING BOTH DPR AND WE
HA. AND AMONG THOSE- WERE AT
SOME OF THE PRIORITIES THAT I
SECRETARY BLUMENFELD MENTIONS
THEY AT TRANSITION TO SAFER MORE
SUSTAINABLE PEST MANAGEMENT
PRACTICES. AS WELL AS PESTICIDE
APPLICATION NOTIFICATION- ONE OF
THE FIRST PROJECTS I WORKED ON
WHEN I CAME TO DPR TO CALLIE PA
AND TWENTY SEVENTEEN- WAS THE
DEPARTMENT'S REEVALUATION OF
POOR PURIFY US BASED ON THE
HUMAN HEALTH RISKS THAT DR
HARLEY MENTIONED- AND AS THE
SECRETARY MENTIONED- DPR TOOK
ACTION TO CANCEL. THE CORPORATE
BUS REGISTRATION AND ALL OF THE
USE OF CHLORPYRIFOS ON OR
VIRTUALLY ALL OF IT ENDED AS OF
THE END OF TWENTY TWENTY. I'M
REALLY EXCITED- TO BE IN THIS
ROLE- BECAUSE I REALLY BELIEVE
IN THE VISION- BUT THE NEW
SEMESTER ADMINISTRATION AND
SECRETARY. OF IDENTIFIED OF
MOVING AWAY FROM HARMFUL
PESTICIDES AND TOWARD SAFER AND
MORE SUSTAINABLE PRACTICES. I
THINK IT'S DR HARLEY MENTIONED-
YOU CAN UNDERSTAND PESTICIDES ON
A RISKY AND SO THE MORE THAT WE
CAN DO TO TRY TO MOVE TO SAFER
PRACTICES- THE BETTER WILL BE
ABLE TO PROTECT PUBLIC HEALTH
AND ENVIRONMENT. I'M ALSO REALLY
EXCITED TO BE IN THIS ROLE
BECAUSE AS THE SECRETARY
MENTIONED IT REQUIRES A GREAT
DEAL OF COLLABORATION AND- I'M
LOOKING FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
THE DPR TEAM- WITH THE SECRETARY
MY COLLEAGUES THAT KELLY PA. OUR
SISTER AGENCIES- AND ALL OF OUR
STAKEHOLDERS AND OF COURSE YOU
THE LEGISLATURE. AND TO REALLY
SEE THAT VISION BECOME A ALITY.
OUR MISSION AT THE MOST
FUNDAMENTAL LEVEL IS REGULATING
PESTICIDES- AND MAKING SURE THAT
THEIR USE IS SAFE ON BOTH FOR
HUMAN HEALTH AND FOR THE
ENVIRONMENT BUT IT'S MUCH MORE
THAN NOT IT'S ALSO FOSTERING THE
USE OF SAFER MORE SUSTAINABLE
PRACTICES AND NOW WE REALLY HAVE
TO ACCELERATE THAT TRANSITION.
WE'RE COMMITTED IN BOTH OF THESE
ROLES TO EQUITY AND
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE ON AS THE
SECRETARY MENTIONED. AND A KEY
PART OF THAT IS ENGAGING
MEANINGFULLY WITH COMMUNITIES TO
ADDRESS THEIR ISSUES AND
CONCERNS ABOUT PESTICIDE USE AND
WORKING TOGETHER TO SOLVE
PROBLEMS. A SECRETARY BLOOMFIELD
LUNCHEON CALIFORNIA IS OFTEN
SOUGHT OUT AS A LEADER IN
ENVIRONMENTAL AND HEALTH MATTERS
AND WE SEEK THAT LEADERSHIP ROLE
AS DPR BOTH AND ARE REGULATORY
EFFORTS. AS WELL AS OUR EFFORTS
TO MOVE TO SAFER AND MORE
SUSTAINABLE PRACTICES. AS THE
SECRETARY MENTIONED AND AS I
NOTED THIS REQUIRES A LOT OF
COLLABORATION ACROSS ALL OF OUR
STAKEHOLDERS AND IT'S NOT EASY
WORK- BUT WE REALLY APPRECIATE
THE COMMITMENT OF SO MANY OF OUR
STAKEHOLDERS WHO HAVE JOINED.
THE SUSTAINABLE PEST MANAGEMENT
WORK GROUP AND ARE WORKING
TOGETHER TO COME UP WITH A
ROADMAP AND GOALS FOR GETTING US
THERE. I'M GONNA TALK ABOUT THE
DEPARTMENT'S REGULATORY WALL AS
IT STANDS TODAY. BUT I THINK
IT'S IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT THAT
ROLE EVOLVES OVER TIME- AS WE
CONTINUE TO LOOK AT NEW SCIENCE
AND SUCH AS BOTHERED DR HARLEY
MENTIONED. I'M TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE'RE KEEPING UP WITH
SCIENCE AND PROTECTING PUBLIC
HEALTH THE ENVIRONMENT. SO AS
QUICK BACKGROUND- ON PESTICIDE
REGULATION THE STATE PASSED ITS
FIRST. PESTICIDE A LAW IN
NINETEEN OH ONE AND UNTIL IN
NINETEEN NINETY ONE THE
DEPARTMENT OF FOOD AND
AGRICULTURE WAS RESPONSIBLE. FOR
REGULATING PESTICIDES- DPR WAS
CREATED IN NINETEEN NINETY ONE
UNDER THE UMBRELLA OF CALLIE PA.
FOLLOWING THE AGENCIES
ESTABLISHMENT- BY GOVERNOR
WILSON THAT SAME YEAR. SO THE
WAY WE MANAGE POTS AFFECTS
PUBLIC HEALTH THE ENVIRONMENT-
AS DR HURLEY NOTED PASS CAN
INCLUDE AND SOCKS- ANIMALS LIKE
INSECTS AND RODENTS UNWANTED
PLANTS LIKE WEEDS. AND ALSO
MICRO ORGANISMS LIKE PLANTS
DISEASES AND VIRUSES THAT CAUSE
DAMAGE ECONOMIC DAMAGE OR
TRANSMIT DISEASE. THEY CAN BE
MANAGED WITH CHEMICAL BIOLOGICAL
CULTURAL AND PHYSICAL TOOLS AND
PRACTICES. I'M STATE AND FEDERAL
LAW TO FIND PESTICIDES AND
SUBSTANCES THAT ARE INTENDED TO
CONTROL DESTROY REPEL OR ATTRACT
PASS. AND ALTHOUGH WE OFTEN
THINK OFAGRICULTURE WHEN WE
THINK OF PESTICIDES- MANY COMMON
HOUSEHOLD PRODUCTS ARE ALSO
PESTICIDES ON ANT SPRAY IS- MY
STATE I. AM DISINFECTANTS ON
PRODUCTS THAT ARE USED TO COLD
MOLD AND MANY A LOT AND GOT HIM
PER CARTON PRODUCTS AS WELL AS-
SWIMMING POOL CHEMICALS. SO
ACCELERATING THE USE OF SAFER
AND MORE SUSTAINABLE APPROACHES-
REQUIRES CONSIDERING WHAT WE USE
HOW WE USE AND WHEN WE USE THOSE
TOOLS AND PRACTICES. INTEGRATED
PEST MANAGEMENT IS AN ECOSYSTEM
BASED STRATEGY THAT FOCUSES ON
THE LONG TERM PREVENTION OF
PAST. AND THEIR DAMAGE THROUGH A
COMBINATION OF TECHNIQUES USING
THE LEAST TOXIC EFFECTIVE
METHOD. TO CONTROL PASSED TO
MINIMIZE RISKS TO HUMAN HEALTH
AND THE ENVIRONMENT. DPR
REGULATES THE USE OF PESTICIDES
IN CALIFORNIA IN A REGULATORY
PROGRAMS PROVIDE THE FOUNDATION
OF THE DEPARTMENT'S MISSION OF
PROTECTING PUBLIC HEALTH AND THE
ENVIRONMENT. THAT WORK BEGINS
WITH EVALUATING EVERY PESTICIDE
BEFORE IT'S USED IN CALIFORNIA.
ALL PESTICIDES USED IN THE US
HAVE TO BE EVALUATED AND
REGISTERED BY THE USEPA AND ALL
PESTICIDES USED IN CALIFORNIA
HAVE TO BE EVALUATED AND
REGISTERED IN THE STATE BEFORE
USE. OUR REGISTRATION CONSIDER
CONSIDERS CALIFORNIA SPECIFIC
CONDITIONS LIKE WEATHER AND SOIL
AND CAN OFTEN CONTAIN MORE
SPECIFIC RESTRICTIONS ARE MORE
PROTECTIVE RESTRICTIONS ON THE
U. S. EPA REGISTRATIONS. OUR
SCIENTIFIC EVALUATION THAT
PROCEEDS REST REGISTRATION AND
ALSO CONTINUES AFTER
REGISTRATION IS DRIVEN BY
EMERGING SCIENCE AND IS AT THE
CORE OF THE DEPARTMENT'S STRICT
REGULATORY AND OVERSIGHT WORK.
BEFORE MAKING A REGISTRATION
DECISION DPR SCIENTISTS EVALUATE
AND ASSESS PESTICIDES HUMAN
HEALTH AND ENVIRONMENTAL RISKS
AND DETERMINE WHETHER THOSE
RISKS CAN BE MITIGATED. WE WILL
NOT REGISTER A PESTICIDE IF
THERE'S RISKS CAN'T BE MITIGATED
. OUR REQUIRED MEDICATION AND
CAN INCLUDE DESIGNATING A
PESTICIDE AS A RESTRICTED
MATERIAL AS A TOXIC AIR
CONTAMINANTS. AND ALSO LIMITS ON
HOW THE PESTICIDE IS USED. THOSE
RESTRICTED MATERIAL PERMITS- ARE
VERY SPECIFIC WITH RESPECT TO
TIME AND PLACE AND INCLUDE
PRACTICES THAT REDUCE ADVERSE A
FAX. LOCAL AYE COMMISSIONERS WHO
GIVE THE PERMITS CAN ALSO DENY
PERMITS AND ALSO IMPOSE
ADDITIONAL RESTRICTIONS ON THEIR
USE BASED ON LOCAL CONDITIONS.
THE DEPARTMENT CAN ALSO
DESIGNATE PESTICIDES AS TOXIC
AIR CONTAMINANTS AND REQUIRE
ADDITIONAL CONTROLS BASED ON THE
USE OF THOSE PESTICIDES. IN
ADDITION TO THOSE TWO FORMS OF
RESTRICTION THE DEPARTMENT MAY
ALSO APPLY RESTRICTIONS TO OTHER
PESTICIDES LIMITING THEIR USE.
AS I MENTIONED ONCE WE REGISTER
A PESTICIDE THAT IS NOT THE END
OF OUR EVALUATION WE CONTINUE TO
EVALUATE ALL PESTICIDES
FOLLOWING THAT REGISTRATION TO
TAKE INTO ACCOUNT EMERGING
SCIENCE WHICH AS YOU CAN TELL
FROM DOCTOR HARLEY'S
PRESENTATION IS REALLY CRITICAL
BECAUSE THE SCIENCE OF FALLS IN
CHANGES. WE REGULARLY MONITOR
AIR SURFACE WATER SOURCES LIKE
CREEKS AND GROUNDWATER WELLS FOR
THE PRESENCE OF PESTICIDES AND
TAKE ACTION TO RESTRICT USE
WHERE PESTICIDE LEVELS EXCEED
THOSE THAT ARE DEFINED BY HEALTH
STANDARDS. OVER THE LAST THIRTY
YEARS WE'VE OPERATED AIR
MONITORING STATIONS AND MORE
THAN TWO DOZEN COUNTIES.
EVALUATED SURFACE WATER AND
THREE HUNDRED EIGHTY LOCATIONS
AND SAMPLED OVER FOUR THOUSAND
UNIQUE WELLS. THE DEPARTMENT'S
AIR MONITORING NETWORK WHICH
ALLOWS US TO MEASURE EXPOSURE
FROM THIRTY ONE DIFFERENT
PESTICIDES HAS LED TO INCREASED
RESTRICTIONS INCLUDING THE USE
OF TARPS FOR FUMIGANT
APPLICATIONS TO REDUCE PESTICIDE
EXPOSURES. ARE WELL MONITORING
HAS RESULTED IN THE DESIGNATION
OF A NUMBER OF PESTICIDES AS
RESTRICTED MATERIALS. WE ALSO
TRACK PESTICIDE USE ILLNESS AND
INJURY REPORTS ADVERSE EFFECTS
REPORTS AND NEW SCIENTIFIC
STUDIES DATA AND FINDINGS FROM
RESEARCHERS OTHER AGENCIES AND
NGOS. IF WE IDENTIFY RISKS
DURING THOSE EVALUATIONS WE
CONSIDER POTENTIAL MEDICATION
OPTIONS THOSE INCLUDE AS THEY DO
WITH THE REGISTRATION STAGE.
DESIGNATING PESTICIDES AS WERE
TO RESTRICT MATERIALS OR TOXIC
AIR CONTAMINANTS REQUIRING YOU
USE CONDITIONS WERE CANCELING
THE PRODUCT AS WE DID IN THE
CASE OF CORPORATE BOSS. RE
CONTINUOUS EVALUATION- RECENTLY
LED TO- FORMAL REEVALUATION OF
THE ADVOCATES MY PESTICIDES AS
SECRETARY BLUMENFELD MENTIONED.
THAT FOLLOWED A SERIES OF
STUDIES THAT SHOW THAT
NEONICOTINOIDS CAN CAUSE HARM TO
POLLINATORS. LAST MONTH WE
PROPOSE REGULATIONS TO ADDRESS
NEONICOTINOID RISKS TO PESTICIDE
TO POLLINATORS. THIS
COMPREHENSIVE REGULATIONS FOLLOW
AND NUANCED TIERED APPROACH TO
LIMITING AGRICULTURAL SETTINGS.
TO LIMITING USE IN AGRICULTURAL
SETTINGS. BASED ON PROPER
TRACKED ADMITS TO BE IS. OVER
THE LAST THIRTY YEARS THE
DEPARTMENT EVALUATIONS AND
RESTRICTIONS AND EFFORTS TO
FOSTER REDUCE PRESS PEST
MANAGEMENT HAVE HELPED LEAD TO
SIGNIFICANT SHIFTS AND PESTICIDE
USE. INCLUDING ORGANIC PHOSPHATE
PESTICIDES LIKE CHLORPYRIFOS
HAVE DECREASED BY SEVENTY NINE
PERCENT. GROUNDWATER
CONTAMINANTS HAVE DECREASED BY
85% PESTICIDES LINKED TO CANCER
AND BIRTH DEFECTS HAVE DECREASED
BY SEVENTY SEVEN PERCENT. AND ON
THE SAFER SIDE ALTERNATIVE BIO
PESTICIDE USE HAS INCREASED BY
SEVEN HUNDRED AND 20% IN
ADDITION TO EVALUATING AND
REGULATING PESTICIDES WE ALSO
HAVE A KEEN FOCUS ON WORKER
HEALTH AND SAFETY AS WELL AS
COMMUNITY HEALTH AND SAFETY. DPR
WORKER HEALTH AND SAFETY
REGULATIONS PROTECT WORKERS WHO
HANDLE OR WORK NEAR PESTICIDES
FROM POTENTIALLY HAZARDOUS
EXPOSURES. THE STATE'S
COMPREHENSIVE STATE WORKER
HEALTH AND SAFETY REGULATIONS
HELPED SHAPE THE FEDERAL WORKER
SAFETY PROTECTION STANDARDS
WHICH BECAME EFFECTIVE
NATIONALLY IN NINETEEN NINETY
FIVE. WE PARTICIPATE REGULARLY
AN OUTREACH AND EDUCATION EVENTS
TO PROVIDE SAFETY INFORMATION TO
PESTICIDE HANDLERS AND FIELD
WORKERS. THIS OUTREACH SUPPORTS
PESTICIDE SAFETY TRAINING THAT
EMPLOYERS ARE REQUIRED TO
PROVIDE TO THEIR EMPLOYEES. THE
DEPARTMENT ALSO DEVELOPED AN
ELECTRONIC REPORTING TOOL WHICH
WE CALL CASPER CALIFORNIA SYSTEM
FOR PESTICIDE INCIDENT
REPORTING. TO ALLOW INDIVIDUALS
TO REPORT PESTICIDE INCIDENTS
AND HONESTLY ON THEIR PHONES.
SINCE THE DEPARTMENT
ESTABLISHMENT THE NUMBER OF
REPORTED PESTICIDE ILLNESSES
AMONG WORKERS HANDLING
PESTICIDES FOR AGRICULTURAL USE
AND STRUCTURAL PEST CONTROL HAS
DECREASED BY 87% IN ADDITION TO
OUTREACH TO COMMUNITIES THE
DEPARTMENT ALSO CONDUCTS
COMMUNITY OUTREACH TO PROMOTE
BROADER PESTICIDE SAFETY OVER
THE PAST DOZEN YEARS WE HAVE
PARTICIPATED IN MORE THAN ONE
THOUSAND COMMUNITY EVENTS TO
PROVIDE INFORMATION ON PESTICIDE
REGULATIONS AND PESTICIDE
SAFETY. WE'VE ALSO BROADCAST
MORE THAN THREE THOUSAND PUBLIC
SERVICE ANNOUNCEMENTS ON SPANISH
AND INDIGENOUS LANGUAGE RADIO
STATIONS ACROSS CALIFORNIA TO
PROVIDE PESTICIDE SAFETY
INFORMATION. INCREASING ACCESS
TO INFORMATION ABOUT PESTICIDE
APPLICATIONSAND IMPROVING
COMMUTING GAUGE RENT ARE
CRITICAL TO THE PARCHMENTS
MISSION OF PROTECTING PUBLIC
HEALTH. THE SECRETARY BLUMENFELD
MENTIONED HOW WE RECEIVE TEN
MILLION DOLLARS IN LAST YEAR'S
BUDGET TO DEVELOP A STATEWIDE
PESTICIDE NOTIFICATION SYSTEM TO
PROVIDE COMMUNITIES WITH ACCESS
TO INFORMATION ABOUT PESTICIDE
APPLICATIONS HAPPENING NEAR
THEM. WE'RE IN THE PROCESS OF
DEVELOPING THAT STATEWIDE SYSTEM
THAT WILL ENABLE COMMUNITY
MEMBERS TO TAKE SIMPLE
PRECAUTIONS TO TAKE ADDITIONAL
MEASURES TO PROTECT THEIR
HEALTH. LIKE BRINGING CHILDREN
INDOORS STAYING AWAY FROM FIELDS
CLOSING WINDOWS SPRINGING IN
LAUNDRY AND TOYS. WE ARE IN THE
PROCESS AND HAVE BEEN GATHERING
FEEDBACK ON THE DESIGN OF THAT
SYSTEM AND PLAN TO HOLD A
WORKSHOP LATER THIS SPRING. LAST
MONTH AT FOUR DIFFERENT COUNTY
AYE COMMISSIONERS ANNOUNCED
PILOTS AND COUNTY LOCATIONS- TO
PILOT NOTIFICATION SYSTEMS THAT
WILL PROVIDE INPUT INTO THE
DESIGN OF OUR STATEWIDE SYSTEM.
THOSE LOCAL PILOT PROJECTS- WILL
LAUNCH OVER THE COURSE OF THE
NEXT FOUR MONTHS AND IN FACT ONE
WAS ANNOUNCED LAST WEEK- IN
RIVERSIDE- THE OTHER COMMUNITIES
ARE LOCATED IN SANTA CRUZ
STANISLAUS AND VENTURA COUNTIES
. COMMUNITY MEMBERS GROWERS AND
OTHERS WILL HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY
TO PROVIDE FEEDBACK TO THEIR
LOCAL I. COMMISSIONERS HE WILL
THEN PROVIDE THAT FEEDBACK TO US
TO HELP US WITH THE DESIGN OF
OUR STATEWIDE SYSTEM. OUR
COMMUNITY FOCUS ALSO INCLUDES
CHILDREN IN SCHOOLS. AS DR
HURLING NOTED CHILDREN ARE
PARTICULARLY VULNERABLE TO
IMPACTS OF PESTICIDE EXPOSURE
AND ARE FOR THAT REASON A
SPECIFIC FOCUS FOR THE
DEPARTMENT. WE OVERSEE THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF REGULATIONS
THAT PROVIDE MINIMUMDISTANCE
STANDARDS FOR CERTAIN
AGRICULTURAL PESTICIDE
APPLICATIONS NEAR PUBLIC
SCHOOLS. AND ALSO CHILD CARE
CENTERS. AND THEY REQUIRE ANNUAL
REPORTING OF ANTICIPATED
PESTICIDE APPLICATION AROUND THE
SITES. OUR CURRENT PESTICIDE
REPORTING REGULATIONS DON'T
PROVIDE THE FINE LEVEL OF DETAIL
TO BE ABLE TO EFFECTIVELY TRACK
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE DISTANCE
REQUIREMENTS AND SO WE HAVE
PROVIDED GUIDANCE. TO AG
COMMISSIONERS TO PROVIDE TO
GROWERS TIP MORE REFINED THEIR
REPORTING SO THAT WE CAN BETTER
TRACK COMPLIANCE AND WE'RE ALSO
CONSIDERING ADDITIONAL
REGULATIONS THAT WOULD HELP
REFINE REPORTING AND ALSO
IMPROVE COMPLIANCE TRACKING. SIR
SHIFTING TO- PUBLIC HEALTH
PROTECTIONS AS IT RELATES TO
FOOD RESIDUES- THE DEPARTMENT
ADMINISTERS THE NATION'S LARGEST
PESTICIDE RESIDUE MONITORING
PROGRAM OF DOMESTIC AND
INTERNATIONAL PRODUCE. WE
CONDUCT INSPECTIONS AT
SUPERMARKETS DISTRIBUTION
CENTERS AND FARMERS MARKETS
ACROSS THE STATE AND CONTRACT
WITH CDFA IS A LOB TO ANALYZE
THE SAMPLES. WE ALSO INSPECT
STORES THROUGHOUT THE STATE FOR
UNREGISTERED PRODUCTS SALES AND
ALSO TRACK INTERNET SALES OF
PESTICIDES NOT REGISTERED IN
CALIFORNIA. EFFECTIVE
ENFORCEMENT OF THE STATE'S
PESTICIDE USE LAWS AND
REGULATIONS IS OF COURSE
ESSENTIAL I'M TO THE
EFFECTIVENESS OF OUR REGULATORY
PROGRAMS. THAT ENFORCEMENT DUTY
IS SHARED BETWEEN DPR AND THE
LOCAL COUNTY AYE COMMISSIONERS.
WE'RE RESPONSIBLE FOR STATE WHAT
ENFORCEMENT AND THE OVERSIGHT OF
OUR STATEWIDE PROGRAM. TO ENSURE
THE LOCAL PROGRAM'S
EFFECTIVENESS. COUNTY AYE
COMMISSIONERS AND THEIR STAFF OF
APPROXIMATELY FOUR HUNDRED
INSPECTORS AND BIOLOGISTS ARE
RESPONSIBLE FOR LOCAL
ENFORCEMENT ACROSS THE STATE'S
FIFTY EIGHT COUNTIES. THEY
PROMOTE COMPLIANCE WITH
PESTICIDE USE LAWS REGULATION
THROUGHOUT REGION EDUCATION AND
NEARLY ALL AND CONDUCT NEARLY
ALL OF THE LOCAL ENFORCEMENT
ACTIVITIES AGAINST PESTICIDE USE
VIOLATIONS. WE PROVIDE GUIDANCE
TO THE AYE COMMISSIONER I
THROUGH THEIR ACTIVITIES THROUGH
OUR WORK PLANS THAT WE WORK WITH
ON THEM. OVERSIGHT INSPECTIONS
TRAINING FOR REGULATION
IMPLEMENTATION RESTRICTED
MATERIAL PERMITTING. INSPECTIONS
AND INVESTIGATIONS WE ALSO MEET
AND ENGAGE REGULATE WHETHER AYE
COMMISSIONER PARTNERS. THEIR
LOCAL ON THE GROUND ENFORCEMENT
EFFORTS ARE CRITICAL TO OUR
ABILITY TO ENFORCE PESTICIDE USE
LAWS IN THE STATE AND KEEP
PEOPLE SAFE. DPR AND AYE
COMMISSIONERS INVESTIGATE
PESTICIDE RELATED COMPLAINTS AND
THE COMMISSIONERS CONDUCT
INSPECTIONS TO ENSURE ALL
PESTICIDE APPLICATORS COMPLY
WITH PESTICIDE PRODUCT
REGISTRATION AND LABELING
REQUIREMENTS. ON AVERAGE OVER
THE LAST THREE YEARS
COMMISSIONERS HAVE CONDUCTED
OVER TWENTY SEVEN THOUSAND
ANNUAL INSPECTIONS. WE HAVE A
AYE COMMISSIONERS ARE JOINTLY
RESPONSIBLE FOR INVESTIGATING
POTENTIAL PESTICIDE RELATED
ILLNESSES OR INJURIES SUCH AS
THOSE CAUSED BY PESTICIDE DRAFTS
EXPOSURE OR EXCEEDING PESTICIDE
CONCENTRATIONS IN AIR. OVER THE
LAST THREE YEARS AYE
COMMISSIONERS HAVE CONDUCTED AN
AVERAGE OF OVER TWENTY THREE
HUNDRED ANNUAL INVESTIGATIONS.
AND I KNOW WE'RE GONNA BE
TALKING LATER THIS MONTH ABOUT
OUR ENFORCEMENT BUDGET REQUEST-
BUT I WANTED TO GET JUST A QUICK
PREVIEW OF OUR REQUEST- WELL
LOCAL I. COMMISSIONER
ENFORCEMENT A PESTICIDE
VIOLATIONS IS APPROPRIATE AND
THE VAST MAJORITY OF CASES IN
CERTAIN SITUATIONS INCLUDING
MULTI JURISDICTIONAL VIOLATIONS
PROGRESSIVE STATE LEVEL
ENFORCEMENT IS APPROPRIATE.
WE'RE PROPOSING CHANGES TO OUR
ENFORCEMENT AUTHORITY TO RESTORE
THE AUTHORITY THAT SUNSET IN TWO
THOUSAND SIX AND ARE ALSO
PROPOSING INCREASES AND CRIMINAL
CIVIL AND ADMINISTRATIVE FINE
LEVELS AN INCREASE FUNDING FOR
STATE LEVEL ENFORCEMENT. FINALS
FOR PESTICIDE USE VIOLATIONS
HAVE REMAINED LARGELY UNCHANGED
FOR DECADES AND NEED TO BE
MODERNIZED TO EFFECTIVELY DETER
VIOLATIONS. AND ACCOUNT FOR
YEARS OF INFLATION AND KEEP PACE
WITH FEDERAL PESTICIDE
ENFORCEMENT PENALTIES. AS AN
EXAMPLE I RECALL CHAU
COMMISSIONERS FOUND AN AERIAL
PESTICIDE APPLICATOR
ADMINISTRATIVELY LIABLE FOR
PESTICIDE USE VIOLATIONS
INCLUDING DRIPPED ONTO A SOCCER
FIELD AND LEVY PENALTIES ON NINE
SEPARATE OCCASIONS IN MULTIPLE
COUNTIES. HIGHER FINES FOR
EARLIER VIOLATIONS MAY HAVE
SERVED AS A BETTER DETERRENT.
REPEAT VIOLATIONS LIKE THIS
REQUIRE ADDITIONAL ENFORCEMENT
TOOLS AND ADDITIONAL PENALTIES
TO DETERMINES CONDUCT.
ADDITIONAL TOOLS AND INCREASE
PENALTIES WILL ALSO SUPPORT THE
DEPARTMENT'S LICENSING VIOLATION
ACTIVITIES. DPR REQUIRES
TRAINING PROFESSIONAL LICENSES
AND CONTINUING EDUCATION FOR
COMMERCIAL PESTICIDE APPLICATORS
WE CURRENTLY MAINTAIN THIRTY
THOUSAND LICENSES AND PROVIDE
TRAINING MATERIALS TO OVER TEN
THOUSAND FOR OVER TEN THOUSAND
ANNUAL EXAMS AND THIRTY TWO
DIFFERENT CATEGORIES COVERING
PESTICIDE LAWS AND REGULATIONS.
THE SAFE AND EFFECTIVE USE OF
PESTICIDES AN INTEGRATED PEST
MANAGEMENT. THIS TRAINING
EXAMINATION AND LICENSING
PROCESS PROMOTES PROFESSIONAL
AND SAFE PEST CONTROL CONDUCTED
BY QUALIFIED AND RESPONSIBLE
LICENSEES. DPR ALSO CERTIFIED
PESTICIDE APPLICATORS WHO USE OR
SUPERVISE THE USE OF RESEARCH
MATERIAL PESTICIDES AND ALSO
LICENSES BUSINESSES THAT SELL OR
APPLY PESTICIDES OR USE PEST
CONTROL METHODS OR DEVICES FOR
HIGHER. OVER THE PAST SEVENTEEN
YEARS WE'VE EXPERIENCED IN OVER
6100% INCREASE IN THE NUMBER OF
LICENSES THAT WE ISSUED WITHOUT
INCREASING FEES OR ADDING
STOPPING TO ACCOMMODATE THE
RELATED INCREASE IN WORKLOAD.
WE'RE REQUESTING FUNDING THIS
YEAR TO COMPLY WITH NEW FEDERAL
CERTIFICATION AND TRAINING
REQUIREMENTS AND TO ADD STOPPING
SO THAT WE CAN TIMELY RENEW
LICENSES. AND PROVIDE GREATER
LANGUAGE ACCESS AND VERIFY
COMPLIANCE WITH CONTINUING LEGAL
EDUCATION TEN EWING EDUCATION
REQUIREMENTS. I'M GOING TO SHIP
NOW FROM THE DEPARTMENT'S
REGULATORY ROLE TO ARE EQUALLY
IMPORTANT ROLE IN FOSTERING AND
NOW ACCELERATING THE USE OF
REDUCED RISK PESTICIDES. AND
MORE SAFE AND SUSTAINABLE BEST
PRACTICES. WE'VE CARRIED OUT OUR
ROLE TO DATE AND SUPPORTING AND
FOSTERING THE USE OF REDUCE
RESPONSE MANAGEMENT BY PROMOTING
THE USE OF INTEGRATED PEST
MANAGEMENT PRACTICES BUT USE THE
LEAST TOXIC. EFFECTIVE METHODS
TO CONTROL PEST PROBLEMS. OUR
DEDICATED INTEGRATED PEST
MANAGEMENT BRANCH ADMINISTERS
INTEGRATED PEST MANAGEMENT
RESEARCH GRANTS THAT INCENTIVIZE
INNOVATION. IN OUR REGION
EDUCATION GRANTS. THAT HELP TO
PROMOTE THE USE UP AND EXPAND
THE USE OF IBM ADOPTION. WITH
THE LEGISLATURE SUPPORT THROUGH
THE BUDGET PROCESS OVER THE LAST
TEN YEARS THOSE GRANTS HAVE
TOTALED NINETEEN MILLION DOLLARS
. IN ADDITION TO GRANTS WE ALSO
PROMOTE I PM LEADERSHIP
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. JUST LAST
MONTH WE CELEBRATED OUR ANNUAL
IPM ACHIEVEMENT AWARDS WHICH
RECOGNIZE ORGANIZATIONS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE THAT USE
INTEGRATED PEST MANAGEMENT
PRACTICES TO ADDRESS THE DIVERSE
PEST MANAGEMENT NEEDS IN
AGRICULTURE AND NON AGRICULTURAL
SETTINGS THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA.
ONE OF OUR AWARDS WENT TO THE
IPM PROGRAM AT ANAHEIM UNION
HIGH SCHOOL DISTRICT IN
RECOGNITION OF THEIR LEADERSHIP
ROLE IN IMPLEMENTING INTEGRATED
PEST MANAGEMENT PRACTICES AND
SCHOOLS. THE DISTRICT'S PROGRAM
FOCUSED ON AND I GET INNOVATIVE
NON CHEMICAL TOOLS SUCH AS
RAFTER PERCHES THAT ATTRACT
RAPTORS TO CONTROL RODENTS. THE
DISTRICTS IPM PROGRAM ELIMINATED
THE USE OF RODENTICIDES AND
SIGNIFICANTLY REDUCED THE USE OF
INSECTICIDES ACROSS TWENTY ONE
DIFFERENT SCHOOL SITES. LAST
YEAR WE CELEBRATED MICHAEL BY
ASKEY A CONSTITUENT ASSEMBLY
MEMBER REBECCA BAUER K. HANDS
DISTRICT WITH THE DISTRICTS WITH
THE DEPARTMENT'S FIRST LIFETIME
IPM ACHIEVEMENT AWARD WE
RECOGNIZED HIS CAREER LONG
ADVOCACY AND EDUCATION BY PM
PRACTICES. AND IS EXPANSION OF
IBM RESEARCH IN BOTH THE PUBLIC
AND PRIVATE SECTORS.
ACCELERATING A SYSTEM WIDE STATE
WIDE TRANSITION TO SAFER MORE
SUSTAINABLE PRACTICES. REQUIRES
MORE THOUGH WE NEED BROADER
STAKEHOLDER ENGAGEMENT AND
COMMITMENT AND AMBITIOUS
TARGETED GOALS SO SECRETARY
BLUMENFELD MENTIONED IN HIS
REMARKS WE IN CFA CONVENE THE
SUSTAINABLE PEST MANAGEMENT WORK
GROUP. TO IDENTIFY PATHWAYS AND
TO SET TARGETED MEASURABLE
AMBITIOUS GOALS TO HELP GET US
TO THAT PLACE. THE WORK GROUP
INCLUDES TWENTY SIX MEMBERS FROM
DIVERSE BACKGROUNDS INCLUDING DR
HARLEY- AS WELL AS GROWERS AND
OTHER REPRESENTATIVES ACROSS THE
AGRICULTURAL SECTOR. ADDITIONAL
UNIVERSITY RESEARCHERS
GOVERNMENT REPRESENTATIVES AND
COMMUNITY AND TRIBAL
REPRESENTATIVES WHO BRING BOTH
ENVIRONMENTAL SOCIAL JUSTICE AND
FARMWORKER PERSPECTIVES. WE
EXPECT THE WORKGROUP TO ISSUE
ITS DRAFT RECOMMENDATIONS AND
PATHWAYS ANGLES LATER THIS
SPRING. AS WE TALKED ABOUT
EARLIER COORDINATION ACROSS
STATE AGENCIES IS REALLY
CRITICAL TO OUR WORK- THE RANGE
OF POTENTIAL IMPACTS FROM THE
USE OF PESTICIDE REQUIRES
DEDICATED COLLABORATION WE
ROUTINELY COORDINATE WITH
FEDERAL STATE AND LOCAL AGENCIES
TO ENSURE CONSISTENT AND
COMPLEMENTARY APPROACH TO
PESTICIDE REGULATION. AND I WANT
TO HIGHLIGHT SEVERAL KEY STATE
PARTNERSHIPS AND EXAMPLES OF
JUST SOME OF A COLLABORATIVE
WORK. OUR AIR MONITORING PROGRAM
STAFF WORK WITH THE AIR
RESOURCES BOARD ON STUDIES TO
MEASURE PESTICIDE AIR
CONCENTRATIONS. WE ALSO ARE
PARTNERING WITH CARB ON A. B.
SIX SEVENTEEN TO WORK WITH
COMMUNITIES TOOK ADDRESS
PESTICIDE EXPOSURE RELATED
CONCERNS. THE OFFICE OF
ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH HAZARD
ASSESSMENT PROVIDES REVIEW
CONSULTATION AND COMMENTS ON THE
DEPARTMENT'S EVALUATION OF THE
HEALTH EFFECTS OF TOXIC AIR
CONTAMINANTS. AND WE ALSO
COORDINATE WITH THE WE HA AND
WORKER HEALTH AND SAFETY
PROTECTIONS INCLUDING THE
MEDICAL SUPERVISION PROGRAM
WHICH PROTECTS AGRICULTURAL
WORKERS WHO REGULARLY HANDLE
HIGHLY TOXIC PESTICIDES. WE WORK
CLOSELY WITH THE STATE WATER
RESOURCES CONTROL BOARD ON OUR
WELL SAMPLING WORK. AND WE'RE
ALSO WORKING WITH THE STATE AND
REGIONAL WATER BOARDS AND
MUNICIPALITIES ON A STATEWIDE
EFFORT TO GENERATE DATA ON
PESTICIDES AND URBAN RUNOFF AND
WATER WAYS TO SUPPORT FUTURE
MITIGATION ACTIVITIES. WE
COORDINATE AND DANGEROUS SPECIES
ACTS PROTECTION STRATEGIES WITH
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
FISH AND WILDLIFE. AND WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FOOD AND
AGRICULTURE CULTURE AS WELL AS
WITH AG COMMISSIONERS. IN
ADDITION TO ENDANGERED SPECIES
PROTECTION WE WORK CLOSELY WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF FOOD AND
AGRICULTURE ON OUR PESTICIDE USE
MITIGATION EFFORTS AND AS I
MENTIONED THERE ARE KEY PARTNERS
IN CONVENING THE SUSTAINABLE
PEST MANAGEMENT WORK GROUP. OUR
WORK PROTECTING PUBLIC HEALTH
AND ENVIRONMENT IS SUPPORTED BY
THE CONDITION OF OUR FUNDING
SOURCES. AND SO I'D NOW LIKE TO
TURN IT OVER TO OUR ACTING CHIEF
DEPUTY CARE MORRISON. TO PROVIDE
AN OVERVIEW OF THE DEPARTMENT'S
RESOURCES THAT HELP US CARRY OUT
OUR MISSION THANK YOU. THANK YOU
AND WELCOME DOCTOR MORRISON.
THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAPLAIN MEMBERS. THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO BE WITH YOU
HERE TODAY MY NAME IS KAREN
MORRISON. AND I'M ACTING CHIEF
DEPUTY DIRECTOR AT TPR. DR
HENDERSON PROVIDED A HIGH LEVEL
OVERVIEW OF THE DEPARTMENTS WORK
TO PROTECT PUBLIC HEALTH AND THE
ENVIRONMENT WHILE ALSO ENSURING
THAT WE HAVE TOOLS TO BE ABLE TO
EFFECTIVELY. ADDRESS PASS
PRESSURES. AND I'M GONNA TALK
ABOUT HOW WE FUNDS THIS WORK.
OUR CURRENT YEAR BUDGET IS ONE
HUNDRED FORTY SEVEN MILLION
DOLLARS AND WITH THIS WERE ABLE
TO SUPPORT CRITICAL WORK OF FOUR
HUNDRED STAFF ACROSS THE STATE.
WE HAVE TWO LOCATIONS IN THE
SACRAMENTO AREA ONE IN FRESNO
COUNTY AND ONE IN ORANGE COUNTY.
AS WELL SUPPORTING ENFORCEMENT
ACTIVITIES AT THE LOCAL LEVEL
THROUGH THE COUNTY AGRICULTURAL
COMMISSIONERS. DEPARTMENT'S CORE
SOURCES OF ON GOING FUNDING COME
FROM THREE MAIN FUNDS THE
MELISSA SPENT OUR PESTICIDE
REGISTRATION FEES AND OUR
LICENSING FEES. AS WELL AS A
SMALL PERCENTAGE OF OTHER
SPECIAL FUNDS AND FEDERAL FUNDS
ALL OF THESE TOGETHER ARE
MANAGED WITHIN OUR DPR FUNDS. IN
RECENT YEARS DPR IS ALSO SEEN AN
INCREASE IN ONE TIME GENERAL
FUND. APPROPRIATIONS TO HELP
SUPPORT THE TRANSITION TO SAFER
MORE SUSTAINABLE PEST MANAGEMENT
PRACTICES AND TOOLS AND OTHER
EMERGING PROBLEM PROJECTS FOR
THE DEPARTMENTS. AS IS THE
MENTION THE PRIMARY SOURCE OF
FUNDING FOR THE DEPARTMENT IS
OUR MILITIAS WHICH PROVIDES 75%
OF THE REVENUE IN THE DPR FUND
AND SUPPORTS A BROAD RANGE OF
PROGRAMS AND ACTIVITIES ACROSS
THE DEPARTMENTS. THE MILLER SAYS
MAN IS LEVIED ON THE SALE OF ALL
PESTICIDES BOTH AGRICULTURAL AND
NON AGRICULTURAL PRODUCTS AT THE
FIRST POINT OF SALE IN
CALIFORNIA AND IS CURRENTLY SET
AT TWENTY ONE MILLS. AND THEY'LL
IS EQUIVALENT TO ONE TENTH OF
ONE SENSE AND SO IN PRACTICE FOR
EVERY HUNDRED DOLLARS OF
PESTICIDE SALES WE COLLECT TWO
DOLLARS AND TEN CENTS OF REVENUE
FOR THE DEPARTMENT. CANNELLA
ASSESSMENT WAS FIRST ESTABLISHED
IN NINETEEN SEVENTY ONE TO
CREATE AN INDUSTRY SUPPORTED FEE
STRUCTURE. THAT WOULD FUND THE
ACTIVITIES OF A GROWING
PESTICIDE REGULATORY PROGRAM.
THIS WAS SIMILAR TO OTHER
ENVIRONMENTAL PROGRAM FUNDING
STRUCTURES. THE MILLISECOND
STATUTE AND WAS LAST ADJUSTED EP
IN TWO THOUSAND FORWARD TO
INCREASE THE CAP THE MELISSA
SMITH FROM SEVENTEEN POINT FIVE.
TO TWENTY ONE MILLS. OF THE
TWENTY ONE MILLS COLLECTED DVRS
I'M ALLOCATE TO THE STATUTORILY
SET. SEVEN POINT SIX MILLS TO
THE COUNTY AGRICULTURAL
COMMISSIONERS TO CARRY OUT AND
ENFORCE PESTICIDE ENVIRONMENTAL
LAWS AND REGULATIONS AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL. LAST YEAR AT THIS
AMOUNTED TO THIRTY FOUR MILLION
DOLLARS THAT WAS ALLOCATED TO
THE COMMISSIONERS OF BASED ON A
NUMBER OF FACTORS. INCLUDING THE
AMOUNT OF PESTICIDES APPLIED IN
THE COUNTY THE NUMBER OF
RESTRICTED MATERIAL PERMITS
ISSUED AND OTHER RELATED WORK.
HOWEVER THE PROVIDED MELISSA
SMITH IS NOT SUFFICIENT TO FULLY
REIMBURSE THE COUNTY
AGRICULTURAL COMMISSIONERS WORK
AROUND PESTICIDE USE ENFORCEMENT
SUPPORTING LESS THAN HALF OF
THEIR ASSOCIATED COSTS. THE
REMAINING FUNDING FOR THE LOCAL
PROGRAMS COMES FROM A VARIETY OF
OTHER FUNDS THE TWO MOST
SIGNIFICANT ARE COUNTY GENERAL
FUNDS AS WELL AS UNCLEAN GAS TAX
THAT'S APPROPRIATED TO THE
COUNTY IS. THERE ALSO SUPPORTED
BY COMMISSIONER IMPOSED FEES AND
PENALTIES AS WELL AS
MISCELLANEOUS PAYMENTS FROM DPR
TO SUPPORT SPECIFIC PROJECTS. IN
ADDITION TO THE TWENTY ONE
MELISSA CEMENTS THAT SUPPORTS
CPR'S PROGRAMS AND THE WORK BY
THE COMMISSIONERS A SEPARATE
THREE QUARTER MILLIGAUSS MINTS
ON AGRICULTURAL PRODUCTS
SUPPORTS PESTICIDE RELATED
PROGRAMS AT THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF FOOD AND AG.
DIMENSIONAL LEVEL OF THE
ASSESSMENT HAS REMAINED THE SAME
FOR THE LAST EIGHTEEN YEARS AND
FOR THE FIRST TEN OR SO YEARS
DPR COLLECTED ENOUGH REVENUE
FROM THE MILLICENT TO SUPPORT
ITS PROGRAMS. BEGINNING IN
TWENTY THIRTEEN DPR IS FUNDED
MOVED INTO A STRUCTURAL
IMBALANCE MEANING THAT WE WERE
EXPENDING MORE AT THE END OF THE
REVENUES THAT WE WERE
COLLECTING. SEVERAL FACTORS LED
TO THE COST PRESSURES THAT HAVE
BEEN FACED BY DPR AND THESE
INCLUDE ONGOING EXPANSION IN THE
SCOPE OF PROGRAMS FOR AT THE
DEPARTMENTS. AND IN SOME CASES
THIS WAS ACCOMPANIED BY AN
INCREASE IN STAFFING LEVELS TO
KEEP UP WITH THE CHANGING IN
INCREASING DEMANDS ON CPR. WE
AND MANY OTHERS ACROSS THE STATE
HAVE ALSO SEEN AN INCREASE IN
EMPLOYEE COMPENSATION BENEFITS
AND RETIREMENT REQUIREMENTS
WHICH ARE SUPPORTED OUT OF OUR
FUNDS. WE ALSO HAVE AN
OBLIGATION THREE TWENTY FOUR
TWENTY FIVE TO PAY DOWN A
SUPPLEMENTAL PENSION PAYMENT
LOAN OF APPROXIMATELY TEN
MILLION DOLLARS TO THE GENERAL
FUND. IN ORDER TO MAINTAIN A
POSITIVE FUND BALANCE
INAPPROPRIATE RESERVE DPR REDUCE
ITSEXPENDITURES IN FISCAL YEAR
NINETEEN TWENTY ON A ONE TIME
BASIS BY TWO POINT FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS. THIS PROMPTED CLOSE
CONSIDERATION OF THE
DEPARTMENT'S BUDGET SITUATION
AND AS A RESULT LAST YEAR TPR
PROPOSED INCREASING AND CHANGING
ITS MELISSA SMITH STRUCTURE IN
ORDER TO ADDRESS THE DEPARTMENT
STRUCTURAL IMBALANCE. AS WELL AS
TO INCENTIVIZE SAFER AND MORE
SUSTAINABLE PEST MANAGEMENT. OF
THAT PROPOSAL DID NOT GO THROUGH
AS A PART OF BUDGET NEGOTIATIONS
DPR RECEIVED ONE MILLION DOLLARS
TO CONDUCT THE STUDY WITH THE
HELP OF AN OUTSIDE VENDOR. TO
IDENTIFY THE APPROPRIATE
STRUCTURE SOURCES AND LEVELS OF
FUNDING THAT WILL ALLOW THE
DEPARTMENT TO CONTINUE TO FILL
ITS MISSION AND VISION. THE
STUDY WILL ALSO EXAMINE THE
CURRENT AND FUTURE FUNDING NEEDS
THE COUNTY AGRICULTURAL
COMMISSIONERS IN THEIR EFFORTS
TO ENSURE COMPLIANCE WITH AND
ENFORCEMENT OF PESTICIDE LAWS.
AND REGULATIONS ACROSS THE
STATE. THE GOALS OF THIS STUDY
ARE TO IDENTIFY HOW TO
SUSTAINABLY SUPPORT.
CALIFORNIA'S PEST MANAGEMENT
PROGRAM AND INCENTIVIZE THE USE
OF SAFER MORE SUSTAINABLE PEST
MANAGEMENT PRACTICES.
STAKEHOLDER ENGAGEMENT IS KEY TO
THIS PROCESS AND WE'RE LOOKING
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH ALL OF
OUR STAKEHOLDERS AS WELL AS YOU
AND YOUR STAFF AT LEAST AS WE
MOVE THROUGH THE CITY PROCESS.
CONSIDERING OUR CURRENT BUDGET
DPR IS FUN BALLOTS FOR THE
BUDGET YEAR IS EXPECTED TO HAVE
A PRUDENT RESERVE IN LINE WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCES
GUIDANCE OF 325% OF OUR
OPERATING BUDGET. THIS IS IN
LARGE PART DUE TO THE INCREASED
MIL REVENUE FROM LAST YEAR. A
MAJORITY OF WHICH WE ASSOCIATE
WITH THE INCREASE IN SALES OF
DISINFECTANTS AS A RESULT OF THE
COBIT NINETEEN PANDEMIC. TO GET
PUT SOME NUMBERS TO THAT WE
COLLECTED TEN MILLION DOLLARS
MORE IN THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE
THAN WE HAD IN THE PREVIOUS
YEAR. I'M AWARE IS ARE MORE
TYPICAL YEAR OVER YEAR INCREASES
ONE TO TWO MILLION DOLLARS.
HOWEVER AT THIS TIME WE BELIEVE
IT WOULD BE IMPRUDENT TO
CONSIDER THIS FUNDING
SUSTAINABLE OR TO COUNT ON THIS
LEVEL- TO MAINTAIN IN FUTURE
YEARS AND TO ADDRESS THE
IMBALANCE. IF THE LEVEL OF THE
ASSESSMENT IS NOT CHANGE IT IS
LIKELY THE FUND BALANCE WILL
CONTINUE TO DECLINE TO THE
POINT. WHERE SUPPORT FOR
EXISTING PROGRAMS AND ACTIVITIES
IS SEVERELY COMPROMISED AND SO
WE'RE LOOKING TO THE SMALL
STUDY. TO REALLY PROVIDE OPTIONS
FOR LONG TERM SUSTAINABLE WAYS
TO SUPPORT THE STATE'S
TRANSITION. TO SAFER MORE
SUSTAINABLE PEST MANAGEMENT. DPR
IS TO OTHER DEPARTMENT SPECIFIC
FUNDING SOURCES ARE FEE BASED
REVENUES THAT SUPPORT THE
PARENTS REGISTRATION AND
LICENSING PROGRAMS. THE
DEPARTMENT HAS THE AUTHORITY TO
INCREASE THESE FEES THROUGH
REGULATION IN ORDER TO SUPPORT
THE FINANCIAL OBLIGATIONS OF
THOSE ACTIVITIES. FIRST IS THE
PESTICIDE REGISTRATION FEES
WHICH ACCOUNTS 416% OF THE
REVENUE COLLECTED IN THE DPR
FUNDS. AND SUPPORTS PESTICIDE
PRODUCT EVALUATION AND
REGISTRATION- WE RAISED THIS FEE
IN OCTOBER OF LAST YEAR IN ORDER
TO SUPPORT THE OVERALL PROGRAM
MANY OF THE COST PRESSURES I
MENTIONED EARLIER ALSO APPLIED
TO THIS PORTION OF OUR FUNDING.
AS WELL AS TO SUPPORT THE
CALIFORNIA PESTICIDE ELECTRONIC
SUBMISSION TRACKING SYSTEM OR
CAL PASSED ON THIS IS A NEW
SYSTEM TO ALLOW US TO STREAMLINE
OUR PAPER BASED REGISTRATION
SYSTEM WHILE MAINTAINING OUR
RIGOROUS SCIENTIFIC EVALUATION
PROCESS TO SUPPORT THE
INNOVATION OF SAFER MORE
SUSTAINABLE PRODUCTS. AS WELL AS
A DECREASE REGISTRATION
TIMELINES- AND WE'RE KICKING OFF
DEVELOPMENTS AS WE SPEAK AND ARE
VERY EXCITED ABOUT THAT. OUR
LICENSING AND CERTIFICATION FEES
ACCOUNT 42% OF THE REVENUE
COLLECTED IN THE DPR FUND. AGAIN
THIS PROGRAM FOCUSES ON THE
EXAMINATION AND LICENSING FOR
THOSE WHO SELL APPLY
COMMERCIALLY OR CONSULT ON THE
USE OF PESTICIDES. WE ARE ALSO
CONSIDERING THE FEE INCREASE FOR
THIS PROGRAM IN THREE YEARS
PENDING APPROVAL OF THE P. C. P.
THAT'S UP FOR CONSIDERATION THIS
YEAR. THE REMAINING SOURCES OF
ONGOING FUNDING FOR DPR ARE A
MIXTURE OF OTHER REGULATORY FEES
MANAGED BY OTHER ENTITIES. THIS
INCLUDES A CANNABIS TAX FUND
ENVIRONMENTAL LICENSE PLATE FUND
AS WELL AS PENALTIES A SMALL
AMOUNT OF FEDERAL FUNDS AND
COLLECTIVELY THESE ACCOUNT 47%
OF OUR DPR FUNDS. THEY MENTIONED
WE ALSO HAVE IN RECENT YEARS
RECEIVED MORE SUPPORT FROM ONE
TIME GENERAL FUND
APPROPRIATIONS- OF THE BIGGEST
OF WHICH OF THESE CAME IN THE
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO BUDGET.
WHERE WE WERE ALLOCATED OR WHERE
THIRTY SIX POINT FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS WAS ALLOCATED OVER TWO
YEARS TO SUPPORT ONE TIME
INVESTMENT THAT DPR. CDFA UC AND
CSU TO ACCELERATE THE TRANSITION
TOWARD SAFER MORE SUSTAINABLE
TOOLS AND PRACTICES. WHICH IS A
TREMENDOUS PRIORITY FOR OUR
DEPARTMENT AND THE
ADMINISTRATION. RESOURCES
RECEIVED FOR THIS FISCAL YEAR
HAVE AUGMENTED GRANT FUNDING FOR
PROJECTS THAT ARE EXPLORING
PESTICIDE ALTERNATIVES AND
SUPPORTING THEIR BROADER
ADOPTION THROUGHOUT REGION
EDUCATION. AND THE ONE TIME
FUNDS OF ALSO PROVIDED THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR DPR TO ENHANCE
ENVIRONMENTAL MONITORING
ACTIVITIES AND CONTINUE TO
STRENGTHEN OUR ENFORCEMENT AND
COMMUNITY ENGAGEMENT ACTIVITIES
. OTHER ELEMENTS OF ONE TIME
GENERAL SUPPORT HAVE GONE TOWARD
THE NOTIFICATION WORK THAT
DIRECTOR HENDERSON MENTIONING
HER REMARKS AS WELL AS
SUPPORTING THE SUSTAINABLE PEST
MANAGEMENT WORK GROUP PROVIDE
GOALS AND RECOMMENDATIONS AROUND
THIS TRANSITION TO SAFER MORE
SUSTAINABLE PEST MANAGEMENT. AND
REALLY TOGETHER ALL OF THESE
FUNDING SOURCES ARE ALLOWING US
IN THE SHORT TERM TO BUILD ON
OUR CORE REGULATORY WORK AS WELL
AS TO REALLY MOVE THE DEPARTMENT
TOWARD ITS VISION FOR THE
FUTURE. SO THAT I'LL HAND IT
BACK TO DIRECTOR HENDERSON FOR
QUICK CLOSE AND THEN HAPPY
ANSWER QUESTIONS. THANK YOU- AND
THANK YOU ALL- I THINK HOPEFULLY
YOU ARE TAKING AWAY- FROM OUR
PRESENTATIONS THAT. THE MOVE TO
A SAFER AND MORE SUSTAINABLE
PEST MANAGEMENT PRACTICES IS
REALLY CRITICAL TO IMPROVE THE
HEALTH OF OUR COMMUNITIES. AS
WELL AS OUR ENVIRONMENT- BUT IT
REQUIRES ADDITIONAL INVESTMENT-
IN INTEGRATED PEST MANAGEMENT
PRACTICES ENFORCEMENT. AS WELL
AS COMMUNITY ENGAGEMENT- WE
REALLY APPRECIATE YOUR INTEREST
IN OUR MISSION AND OUR WORK- AND
ARE HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS THAT YOU MAY HAVE.
WELL THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
THE- PRETTY DETAILED TEST
SUMMARY OF ALL THE IMPORTANT TO-
WORK THAT YOU DO AND- FISCAL
UNDER PENDING SEC- THAT TO HELP
MAKE IT HAPPEN AND THAT OF
COURSE IS THE- CHAIR OF- THE-
BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE THAT
OVERSEES ALL OF THE SIDE BEEN
WELL AWARE FOR QUITE SOMETIME
THAT THEIR- STRUCTURAL
IMBALANCE. HAS BEEN SOMETHING
THAT THAT WE NEED TO ADDRESS
AND- HOPEFULLY WE'LL BE ABLE TO
DO THAT OF THIS YEAR- WILL OPEN
IT UP FOR QUESTIONS NOW AND I'VE
GOT A- A COUPLE OF KICKED THINGS
OFF WITH ONE. OF IS A QUESTION
THAT- THAT- CHAIR- QUIRK TEXTED
ME AND ASKED- THAT I- I ASKED
THE QUESTION OF A- DR. HARLEY
BUT I'LL PARAPHRASE THAT- AND-
DIRECTOR PERHAPS- YOU CAN- GIVE
US SOME INSIGHT- DOCTOR COURT
CUT- OBSERVES THAT TO- ALL OF
THE ORGANIC FAST PHOSPHATES HAVE
THE SAME CHEMISTRY AS A
CORPORATE. PLUS AND WE'VE ONLY
ELIMINATED- THAT TO- ONE- THAT-
PRODUCT. DO WE HAVE PLANS TO GO
BEYOND THAT OR IS THERE
INVESTIGATORY WORK THAT'S SAID
THAT'S HAPPENING NOW IN THAT
REGARD. THANK YOU IN AND I WILL-
I'LL TAKE- THE FIRST STAB AT
THAT ANSWER AND THEN- I WILL
ENGAGE DOCTOR MORRISON WHO IS A
SCIENTIST. TO HELP OUT WITH THE
RESPONSE BUT AS I MENTIONED- I
SHOULD START BY SAYING WE HAVE
THE GREATEST CONCERN- FOR
CHILDREN'S HEALTH AND RECOGNIZE-
THE DANGEROUS EFFECTS OF ORGANIC
PHOSPHATES. ON THEIR HEALTH- WE
CONTINUOUSLY EVALUATE NEW
SCIENCE AND STUDIES THAT COME
OUT- THAT IDENTIFY ADDITIONAL
RISKS AND HARMS. FOR ALL
PESTICIDE PRODUCTS INCLUDING
ORGANIC PHOSPHATES- AND AT ANY
ONE TIME WILL WILL HAVE A NUMBER
OF PESTICIDES AND REEVALUATION-
BUT ALSO TURNED OVER TO KAREN TO
TALK ABOUT ANY SPECIFIC- ORGANIC
PHOSPHATE RELATED- EVALUATIONS.
YES THANK YOU IT SAID DR GRACE
IS A VERY FAIR POINT THAT THERE
IS A LOT OF OVERLAPPING
CHEMISTRY IS WITHIN THE ORGANIC
PHOSPHATE CLASS AND SO WE LOOK
AT A COMBINATION OF THAT USE
RECORDS THAT WE HAVE WHICH ARE
SHOWING AN OVERALL DECREASE IN
USE OF THOSE PRODUCTS OVER THE
LAST TWENTY YEARS. AS WE'RE
CONSIDERING OUR EVALUATIONS- AND
WE'RE ALSO LOOKING TOWARD AND AS
WE MOVE THROUGH THE ACTION
CORPORATE BOSS ONE OF THE KEY
ELEMENTS THAT WE HEARD WAS A
DESIRE TO REALLY THINK.
HOLISTICALLY ABOUT THE SYSTEM
AND WHAT TOOLS ARE AVAILABLE AND
SO I'M ARE ANTICIPATING THAT THE
CONVERSATIONS THAT ARE COMING
OUT OF THE SAMPLE PEST
MANAGEMENT WORK GROUP AND OTHER
PLACES ARE GONNA BE HELPFUL AS
WERE THINKING HOLISTICALLY ABOUT
WHAT TOOLS ARE AVAILABLE TO
MANAGE AND SEX AND HOW THAT FITS
IN WITH THE RISKS IDENTIFIED.
FORGET ABOUT STATES. GREAT THANK
YOU- NOW- BURKE EVERYONE OF OUR
WITNESSES TODAY INCLUDING
YOURSELF HAVE MENTIONED. A FOCUS
ON CHILDREN WHICH I THINK WE
WOULD ALL AGREE- IS EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT- A DOCTOR HARLEY-
SPOKE SPECIFICALLY ABOUT- THE
IMPACT ON. BRAIN DEVELOPMENT IN
CHILDREN I'M CURIOUS HOW YOU ARE
DEFINING THE CATEGORY OF
CHILDREN WHAT AGES- ARE YOU
ACTIVELY LOOKING AT-
UNDERSTANDING THAT THERE IS A-
LARGE. BODY OF RESEARCH AND
EVIDENCE THAT- BRAIN
DEVELOPMENT- DOESN'T END WITH
CHILDHOOD IT CONTINUES ON INTO.
ADOLESCENCE AND EARLY ADULTHOOD
. I'LL START AND THEN TURNED
OVER TO KAREN I THINK I JUST
AGAIN GOING BACK. AND LOOKING
OUT ON THE PROCESS OF CONTINUOUS
EVALUATION SO WE ARE ALWAYS
LOOKING AND I AM LOOKING NOT
JUST ON CHILDREN BUT AS YOU
MENTIONED- SHARPLY ON THE
AFFECTS OF- OF ON ON BRAIN
HEALTH OF ADULTS AS WELL- SO I
JUST WANTED TO NOTE THAT THAT
THOSE. ALL SENSITIVE POPULATIONS
ARE PART OF- OUR REVIEW- BUT ALL
TURNED OVER TO DOCTOR MORRISON
TO TALK SPECIFICALLY ABOUT HOW
WE DEFINE CHILDREN SO WE DEFINE
CHILDREN AS AS MINOR SEVEN
SEVENTEEN AND UNDER OUR
EVALUATIONS TEND TO FOCUS ON-
THE MOST SENSITIVE POPULATIONS
WHICH IS OFTEN. ON WOMEN OF
REPRODUCTIVE AGE AS WELL AS
CHILDREN AGE TO IN TERMS OF WHAT
WE'VE SEEN FOR THE HIGHEST
LIKELIHOOD EXPOSURE TO
PESTICIDES AS WELL AS WHERE I'M
THERE'S KEY MILESTONES IN BRAIN
DEVELOPMENT BUT AGREE THAT
THAT'S NOT THE ONLY TIME WHEN
THAT HAPPENS AND SO. ON THAT
EVALUATION HAPPENS ON A
PESTICIDE BY PESTICIDE CASE
DEPENDING ON WHAT DATA IS
AVAILABLE. TO BE ABLE TO SUPPORT
THAT ANALYSIS. THANK YOU. MATHIS
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MY
QUESTIONS GO TOWARDS- YOU
BROUGHT UP THE CAL PASS SYSTEM-
SO JUST KIND OF THE BRIEF ON ON
HOW IT'S GOING AND THEN YOU KNOW
THE MILES STONES DATA YOU ARE
USING TO ENSURE THAT THE PROGRAM
IS BEING COMPLETED AS ORIGINALLY
DESIGNED WITH THE BUDGET BECAUSE
WE KNOW IN THE PAST THESE
ELECTRONIC PROGRAMS OF STRUGGLED
IN A FAILED SO WHAT WHAT IS
BEING DONE TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE'RE ON TRACK THAT WE'RE
MEETING THE MILESTONES AND WHAT
DOES THAT LOOK LIKE. THANK YOU
FOR THE QUESTION AND I
APPRECIATE THAT THIS IS- THERE'S
A CHALLENGE FOR ELECTRONIC
SYSTEMS WITH THE STATE AND
CERTAINLY WE'VE SEEN THAT WITH
THE DEVELOPMENT OF THE SYSTEM AS
WELL. WHAT WE'VE DONE IN
APPROACHING- THE SYSTEM IS
REALLY LEARNING FROM OUR PAST
EXPERIENCES WITH DEVELOPMENT AS
WELL AS LOOKING AT OTHER. AND
SSTEMS TO REALLY TRY TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE ARE. TAKING INTO
ACCOUNT RISKS FROM SYSTEM
DEVELOPMENT AS WELL AS
ADDRESSING STAKEHOLDER CONCERNS
WITH THAT SO THERE'S A NUMBER OF
DIFFERENT ELEMENTS THAT WERE
ADOPTING THAT ARE THERE NEW TO
OUR DEVELOPMENT PROCESS. ONE IS
A WORK TO RATHER THAN BUILD UP
TO A SINGLE SYSTEM RELEASED AT
THE END OF DEVELOPMENT WE'RE
LOOKING TO HAVE MODULES RELEASED
OVER THE PERIOD OF THE NEXT. ON
TWO TO THREE YEARS THAT THERE
ARE- SO THEY ARE STAKEHOLDERS
ARE SEEING THAT DEVELOPMENT ABLE
TO START. MOVING AWAY FROM OUR
PAPER BASIS IN THIS QUICKLY AS
POSSIBLE AS WELL. PAYMENTS WHICH
WILL ALSO COME WITH THE SYSTEM
WE KNOW IS A KEY CONCERN. AND WE
HAVE AT LEAST QUARTERLY
STAKEHOLDER MEETINGS THAT WERE
WORKING TO SCHEDULE TO BE ABLE
TO. TEST OUT THE SYSTEM RECEIVE
FEEDBACK PROVIDE UPDATES ON THE
CURRENT STATUS. I'M AND ALSO
HAVE A NUMBER OF DIFFERENT
OVERSIGHT ELEMENTS WITH THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
TECHNOLOGY AND DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE TO. MAKE SURE THAT WE
ARE ON TRACK WITH THE WORK THAT
WE'RE DOING SO WE'VE GOTTEN TO
CONTRACT I BELIEVE LAST MONTH.
ON AND ARE WORKING ON STARTING
TO DEVELOP AND SORE EXPECTING TO
HAVE SOME OF THOSE MILESTONES OF
NEW PRODUCTS RELEASED LATER THIS
YEAR. THANK YOU I'M WORKING ON
WITH SIMILAR- SALAS ON ON A-
TECHNOLOGICAL BILL FOR THE STATE
TO KIND OF. GET OUR SYSTEMS UP
TO DATE. SO IT'S KNOWING HOW
THESE THINGS ARE GOINGCOMING
ALONG. ALSO GOES TO THE TO THE
VAN OF THAT BECAUSE WE'VE SEEN
IT NOT JUST YOUR AGENCY BUT
ACROSS THE WHOLE. THAT THE STATE
NEEDS TO GET CAUGHT UP- BUT ON
THIS ONE ESPECIALLY BECAUSE IT'S
IMPORTANT TO OUR COMMUNITIES AND
TO. OUR PARTNERS AGRICULTURE TO
MAKE SURE THAT THE SYSTEMS WORKS
OTHER SAFE AND EFFECTIVE. THANK
YOU. ASSEMBLY MEMBER SMITH.
THANK YOU CHAIR BLOOM- JUST TO
HIGHLIGHT OUT OF OUR FOUR
HUNDRED EMPLOYEES HOW MANY ARE
IN THE ENFORCEMENT DEPARTMENT. I
HAVE TO CONFIRM THE NUMBER WHEN
I GET BACK TO MY OFFICE I WANNA
SAY IT'S BALLPARK SEVENTY FIVE
BUT I CAN CONFIRM AND GET BACK
TO THE BILL ONE OF MY DOCTORS
OF. THE IN THE MEDIA REPORTS
HAVE BEEN HIGHLIGHTING THE
FAILURE DE PR. AND THE HEALTHY
SCHOOL ACT. TO PROTECT OUR
CHILDREN WHICH WE JUST SPOKE
ABOUT. AND NOTIFYING THE
PARENTS. WHAT HAS THE DEPARTMENT
DONE TO ADDRESS THOSE ISSUES. SO
IS THE ERROR I JUST WANNA MAKE
SURE I UNDERSTAND YOUR QUESTION
NUMBER SMITH- SO IS THIS RELATED
TO THE COMPLIANCE WITH- THE
RESTRICTIONS ON APPLICATIONS
AROUND SCHOOLS HOME I JUST GOT A
REPORT THAT THE NEWS MEDIA IS
REPORTING THAT THERE'S NO
ENFORCEMENT FOR THE- SO I SO THE
CHALLENGE THAT- WE'RE CURRENTLY
EXPERIENCING. AS WITH THE
REFINEMENT IN THE LEVEL OF
REPORTING THAT WE REQUIRE
THROUGHOUT REGULATION SO- IT
REQUIRES REPORTING FIVE
APPLICATIONS ON FIELDS AND THE
SCHOOLS REGULATIONS- LIMIT
CERTAIN APPLICATIONS WITHIN A
QUARTER MILE OF A SCHOOL. AND SO
THE REPORTING THAT REPORTS ON A
FIELD THAT STRADDLES THAT
QUARTER MILE. BUFFER ZONE AND-
THE AREA OUTSIDE OF IT- ISN'T
SUFFICIENTLY REFINED TO TRACK
COMPLIANCE AND SO WHAT WE ARE
DOING NOW IS PROVIDING GUIDANCE
TO LOCAL AG COMMISSIONERS TO
GUIDE THEIR GROWERS TO BETTER TO
REPORT. WHAT APPLICATIONS ARE
HAPPENING- WITHIN THAT QUARTER
MILE IN AT WHAT TIME SO THAT WE
CAN EVALUATE WHETHER THEY ARE
COMPLYING WITH THE RESTRICTIONS
ON THE TIMING RESTRICTIONS ON
APPLICATIONS. AND THEN WE'RE
ALSO LOOKING AT. REVIEWING OUR
REGULATIONS TO DETERMINE WHAT
POTENTIAL CHANGES TO IMPROVE THE
REPORTING REQUIREMENTS. AS WELL
AS COMPLIANCE TRACKING. IN ORDER
FOR MORE IS THERE ANY. ON THE
ILLEGAL MARIJUANA GROWS THAT ARE
PREVALENT THROUGHOUT THE STATE
ORDERS WILL SHARE FOR THE COUNTY
OR WHOEVER'S GONNA CONTACT YOU
TO SAY THAT WE HAVE YOU. DO YOU
GO OUT ON ANY OF THOSE. SO WE
ARE RESPONSIBLE FOR PROVIDING
GUIDANCE ON THE USE OF
PESTICIDES FOR LEGAL GROWS BUT
WE DO COORDINATE WITH LAW
ENFORCEMENT- AS REQUESTED ON
ILLEGAL GROWS. AND ALSO HAVE
PROVIDED GUIDANCE- FOR THE TYPES
OF PESTICIDES THAT MAY BE
PRESENT AT ILLEGAL GROWS SO THAT
FIRST RESPONDERS ARE OTHERS WHO
ARE GOING TO THOSE SITES. ARE
AWARE OF POTENTIALLY DANGEROUS
MATERIALS THAT MAY BE PRESENT.
THANK YOU. WELL THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR YOUR PRESENTATION IS
VERY INTERESTING AND OF COURSE
WE APPRECIATE THEM. WE'RE GOING
TO MOVE ON TO PUBLIC COMMENT
VERY MUCH APPRECIATE IT THANK
YOU VERY WELCOME. I'D LIKE TO
INVITE THE PUBLIC TO COME UP TO
THE MICROPHONE ONE AT A TIME TO
PRESENT YOUR TESTIMONY FOR HER
IN THE ROOM- AND AFTER WITNESSES
WITH US IN THE ROOM HAVE
PRESENTED. WE WILL OPEN THE
PHONE LINES HER TESTIMONY.
YOU'LL EACH HAVE TWO MINUTES TO
SPEAK. I'M I'D TO. LOOKS LIKE WE
MAY HAVE A HALF DOZEN PEOPLE OR
SO WHO IN THE ROOM HERE WHO
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK BUT- FOR
THOSE OF YOU WHO WANT TO
PROVIDE. PHONE TESTIMONY PLEASE
NOTE THAT THE PHONE NUMBER IS
EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN SIX NINE TWO.
EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN. AND THE
ACCESS CODE IS. ONE THREE ONE
FIVE FOUR FOUR FOUR. THAT CELL
PHONE NUMBER EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN
SIX NINE TWO EIGHT NINE FIVE
SEVEN. AND THE ACCESS CODE OF.
ONE THREE ONE FIVE FOUR FOUR
FOUR. FOR WILL BEGIN WITH A-
ANYONE IN THE ROOM HERE WHO
WOULD LIKE TO GIVE PUBLIC
TESTIMONY. MAYBE I WAS WRONG
AND- SAYING A HALF DOZEN PEOPLE
WERE WAITING LOOKS LIKE
MELENDEZ- THAT'S WHY I AM NOT A
SCIENTIST. SO FOR THOSE OF YOU
WHO WISH TO GIVE TESTIMONY BY
PHONE AGAIN THE NUMBERS.
877-692-8957 ACCESS CODE ONE
THREE ONE FIVE FOUR FOUR FOUR.
OPERATOR ARE YOU OUT THERE. YES
WE HAVE ONE- HERE LINE NINE-
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
THAT CHAIR AND MEMBERS NICKEL
CAN UNITS ON BEHALF OF THE
HOUSEHOLD AND COMMERCIAL
PRODUCTS. OUR MEMBERS PRODUCE A
VARIETY OF NON AGRICULTURAL
PESTICIDE LIKE DISINFECTANT PET
CARE PRODUCTS AND HOME BACK TO
CONTROL PRODUCT FIRST WE WANT TO
THANK- THE STAFF AT CPR WHO
TRANSITIONED TO WORKING REMOTELY
AT THE BEGINNING OF CO THAT ADDS
THE DIRECT OF US WHILE THEY WERE
STILL ABLE TO PRIORITIZE
REGISTERING PRODUCT. APPROVED TO
COMBAT THE- THAT WE DO BELIEVE
IT'S IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT NON
ACT PESTICIDES ACCOUNT FOR
APPROXIMATELY 50% OF THE REVENUE
DEPARTMENT RECEIVED THROUGH THE
MAIL TAX. HOWEVER THE AMOUNT OF
GRANT FUNDS DISTRIBUTED BY THE
DEPARTMENT- WITH THOSE FUNDS ARE
PRIMARILY FOCUSED ON
AGRICULTURAL PRACTICES. AND
WHILE THE AMOUNT CHARGED THESE
AND ALL TAX HAS NOT BEEN
INCREASED THAT TO TOWARD EARLY
SINCE TWO THOUSAND FOR. THE
AMOUNT OF MONEY COLLECTED VIA
THE MAIL HAS INCREASED OVER THAT
TIME AS NOTED BY DEPUTY DIRECTOR
MARCIN. WE LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH DEPARTMENT ON THE
NOT TAX STUDY. IMPACTED
STAKEHOLDERS AND LASTLY IF DPR
IT DOES INTEND TO IMPLEMENT A
TRANSITION BUT THEY PURPOSE
MANAGEMENT. TO THE EXTENT THAT
BACK TRANSITIONAL REQUIRED NEW
PRODUCTS REGISTERED IN THE STATE
WE SELL IT IS IMPERATIVE STRONG
ATHLETES NOBLE AND PREDICTABLE
REGISTRATION TIMELINE. IN ORDER
TO BRING NEW PRODUCTS TO MARKET
WHICH WILL BENEFIT. THE PEOPLE
IN THE STATE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU OPERATOR THERE ANY OTHER
WITNESSES- WISHING TO GIVE
TESTIMONY. PUBLIC COMMENT TIME
THERE'S NO ONE I THINK YOU. ALL
RIGHT. WELL THANK YOU VERY MUCH
EVERYONE FOR BEING HERE TODAY WE
LEARNED A LOT ABOUT DVRS EFFORTS
TO IMPLEMENT A ROBUST. I LOST MY
PLACE. A ROBUST PESTICIDE
REGULATORY PROGRAM AND ABOUT ITS
WORK TOWARD PROTECTING HUMAN
HEALTH AND THE ENVIRONMENT DR
CORK AND I ARE BOTH KEENLY
INTERESTED IN OUR STATES
TRANSITION TO SAFER AND MORE
SUSTAINABLE PEST MANAGEMENT
PRACTICES AS I'M SURE EVERYONE
IS AND OUR STAFF AND WE WILL BE
FOLLOWING CLOSELY THE P. R.'S
PROGRESS. TOWARDS THIS GOAL.
ESPECIALLY AS WE MAKE DECISIONS
REGARDING DVRS FUNDING AND
ENFORCEMENT AUTHORITY AS PART OF
THE BUDGET PROCESS. AS I
MENTIONED BEFORE WE PLAN TO HAVE
AT LEAST ONE MORE HEARING
POSSIBLY MORE THAN ONE EXAMINING
IN MORE DETAIL WHETHER AT THE
MANY PROGRAMS UNDER DVRS
JURISDICTION ARE SUPPORTING THIS
TRANSITION AND ARE PROTECTING
OUR COMMUNITIES AND ENVIRONMENT.
I WANT TO REITERATE THAT- MY
DOOR PHYSICAL AND ELECTRONIC IS
ALWAYS OPEN TO MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC ON THIS ISSUE AS IS DR
QUIRKS. AND AS A REMINDER WE
WILL KEEP THE STM COMMITTEE
RECORD OPEN FOR TWO WEEKS UNTIL
MARCH TWENTY SECOND FOR
ADDITIONAL WRITTEN COMMENTS. SO
IF YOU'D LIKE TO SUBMIT WRITTEN
PUBLIC COMMENT. WE ARE HAPPY TO
RECEIVE IT AND PLEASE CONTACT
ASTM STAFF PIA ESTRADA. ONCE
AGAIN I THANK YOU ALL FOR BEING
HERE TODAY AND WE ARE NOW
ADJOURNED.